Tell me the tale of a man, Mews, who had so many roundabout ways, to wander, driven off course after sacking Troy's hallowed cape. Many of the peoples whose cities he saw, and whose ways of thinking he learned, many of the toils he suffered at tea, anguish in his heart as he struggled to safeguard his life, and the homecoming of his companions. But he did not save his companions even so, though he longed to, for the heedlessness destroyed them. There's and nobody else's. Fools that they were, like children who devoured the sun god Hyperion's cattle. And so he took from them the day of their homecoming.
讲述一个男人的故事，缪斯，他有那么多迂回曲折的道路，在洗劫了特洛伊神圣的岬角后，偏离了航向。他见识了许多民族的城市，了解了他们的思维方式，在海上遭受了许多苦难，心中充满了痛苦，努力保全自己的生命，以及同伴的归乡。但即便如此，他也没能拯救他的同伴，尽管他渴望这样做，因为他们的鲁莽毁灭了他们。那是他们自己的错，没别人什么事。他们真是愚蠢，就像吞食了太阳神许珀里翁牛群的孩子们。于是，他夺走了他们归乡的日子。
Goddess, start where you will. Daughter of Zeus, share the tale with us too. So that was the opening of Homer's great epic, The Odyssey, brilliantly translated by a friend of the show, Daniel Mendelsohn. And there was only one person who was capable of reading that for us. And we're very grateful to the tremendous classical actor, Russell Crow, for reading those words. And the reason that Russell agreed to do that for us is because the Odyssey is one of the great foundational moments, the foundational products in all Western culture and civilization.
女神，从你愿意的地方开始吧。宙斯的女儿，也请与我们分享这个故事。这就是荷马史诗《奥德赛》的开篇，由节目的朋友丹尼尔·门德尔松精彩翻译。只有一个人有能力为我们朗读这段文字。我们非常感谢伟大的古典派演员罗素·克劳朗读了这些文字。罗素之所以同意为我们这样做，是因为《奥德赛》是西方文化和文明中伟大的奠基时刻、奠基作品之一。
It ranks alongside Homer's other great poem, the Iliad composed in the 8th or the 7th century BC, and of course the Bible as an absolute building block of the culture that we now are so familiar with Tom. So The Odyssey has given us so many other stories, hasn't it? You've said that it's kind of foundational work of Western culture, but it's in all kinds of ways a foundational work of Western literature. And possibly beyond that, because there are theories that perhaps the Sinbad cycle, the story of Sinbad the Sailor in the Arabian Knights, that perhaps that derived from the Odyssey, because I guess the central core idea is a pretty obvious one when you think about it, which is about a man far from home trying to get back to his wife, to his soul. son to his homeland. This episode is brought to you by the Lloyd's 5K house deposit, and this is something that was last seen in 1996.
它与荷马的另一部伟大诗作——创作于公元前8世纪或7世纪的《伊利亚特》，当然还有《圣经》并列，是我们现在非常熟悉的文化的绝对基石，汤姆。所以《奥德赛》给了我们这么多其他的故事，不是吗？你说过它是西方文化的奠基之作，但在各方面它也是西方文学的奠基之作。甚至可能不止于此，因为有理论认为，或许《辛巴达历险记》（《一千零一夜》中辛巴达的故事）可能源自《奥德赛》，因为我想当你仔细思考时，其核心思想是非常明显的，那就是一个远离家乡的男人试图回到他的妻子、他的儿子、他的祖国身边。本集由劳埃德银行5K房屋首付赞助，这是1996年最后一次出现的东西。
Yeah, so the 1990s looks now like a lost golden age of prosperity and positivity, doesn't it? Think of the sort of the advent of the Blair administration in 1997, all the enthusiasm and excitement that surrounded that, the economic growth at the time, the technological developments, sort of sense of an endless golden summer where everybody is listening to Blur and Oasis and looking forward to buying their first houses. And that of course takes us to mortgages. Now, the good news is that in a nod to the 1990s, Lloyds are offering 5K deposit mortgages to first-time buyers. So search 5K first-time buyer. 1996 average first-time buyer deposits are based on ONS data, subject to status, may be repossessed if you don't keep up repayments and conditions apply.
是的，所以20世纪90年代现在看起来像是一个失落的繁荣与积极的黄金时代，不是吗？想想1997年布莱尔政府的出现，围绕着它的所有热情和兴奋，当时的经济增长，技术发展，那种无尽的黄金之夏的感觉，每个人都在听Blur和Oasis的歌，期待着购买他们的第一套房子。当然，这把我们带到了抵押贷款。现在，好消息是，为了向20世纪90年代致敬，劳埃德银行为首次购房者提供5K首付抵押贷款。所以搜索“5K首次购房者”。1996年平均首次购房者首付基于ONS数据，视具体情况而定，如果您不按时还款，房产可能会被收回，且适用相关条件。
This episode is brought to you by Accenture. When your advertising operations fall out of sync, everything else follows. Spotify and Accenture are working together to reinvent the rhythm of ad sales, using automation, analytics and smarter workflows to simplify campaign delivery and access better data across the business. The result? Less time spent on operations, more time connecting brands with the moments and fandoms that matter most.
本集由埃森哲赞助。当您的广告运营不同步时，其他一切都会随之受到影响。Spotify和埃森哲正在合作重塑广告销售的节奏，利用自动化、分析和更智能的工作流程来简化广告系列投放，并获取整个业务中更好的数据。结果如何？减少在运营上花费的时间，增加将品牌与最重要的时刻和粉丝群体联系起来的时间。
Learn more at Accenture.com slash Spotify. And in Greek, he has this kind of desperate yearning for a Nostos, they called it, this return back home. And on this journey, along the way, he meets with monsters and he meets with menacing alien environments. And he has brushes with powers beyond the limits of mortal understanding. And on top of that, there are. strange distortions of time and space. You have multiple narratives and you have these kind of dizzyingly subjective experiences. So it is, I mean, you know, people have suggested that everything
在Accenture.com/Spotify了解更多信息。在希腊语中，他有一种对“Nostos”的绝望渴望，他们称之为回归故里。在这段旅程中，他遇到了怪物，遇到了威胁性的异域环境。他与超越凡人理解极限的力量有过接触。最重要的是，还有时空的奇怪扭曲。你有多种叙事，还有这种令人眩晕的主观体验。所以，我的意思是，你知道，人们曾暗示《奥德赛》中讲述的一切
that it is just tells us in The Odyssey may actually not be true. I mean, we don't know. And that is kind of part of the fascination. It's in one level of very simple story, a man trying to get back home. And on the other, it's kind of brilliantly sophisticated and meta. You made it sound like conception or something. You know the Christopher Nolan film where Leonardo DiCaprio is trying to get back home to his kind of, to his kids. And actually,
可能根本不是真的。我的意思是，我们不知道。而这正是其魅力的一部分。它在某种层面上是一个非常简单的故事，一个男人试图回到家。而在另一方面，它又是极其复杂和元叙事的。你把它说得像《盗梦空间》之类的。你知道克里斯托弗·诺兰的那部电影，莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥试图回到他的家，回到他的孩子们身边。事实上，
that's not a coincidence because playing with time, a central character who's trying to return to something, meeting with monsters, flashbacks, flash forwards, a sort of dizzying whirl of events and you're never quite sure exactly where you are. Those are very Christopher Nolan
这并非巧合，因为玩弄时间、一个试图回归某处的中心人物、遇到怪物、闪回、闪前、一种令人眩晕的事件旋风，你永远无法确定自己到底身处何处。这些都是非常克里斯托弗·诺兰式的
obsessions. And Christopher Nolan, by an extraordinary coincidence, has made a film of The Odyssey that is coming out later this week, Tom, on the 17th of July. There's been a lot of conversation about The Odyssey recently. Quite a few controversies already thrown up before people have even seen the film. From the trailers and stuff, right? From the trailers. And so we will be having a bonus with Daniel Mendelsohn to talk about that, and that will be out later this week.
痴迷。而克里斯托弗·诺兰，非常巧合地，制作了一部《奥德赛》电影，将于本周晚些时候，也就是7月17日上映，汤姆。最近关于《奥德赛》的讨论很多。在人们甚至还没看到电影之前，就已经出现了不少争议。从预告片之类的东西开始，对吧？从预告片开始。所以我们将有一个与丹尼尔·门德尔松的特别节目来讨论这个问题，该节目将于本周晚些时候发布。
So, massive sense of anticipation. But it's not the only reason, I think, for doing The Odyssey on The Restless History. because to be honest, it's a story that I've been wanting to do since we began the podcast. And I want to look perhaps a little bit at the context. So how did it come to be composed? Is anything in the story true? Is it, you know, to what degree might it be based on fact? What mirror might it hold up to the reality of the ancient Mediterranean, whether that's the time that Odysseus is supposed to have lived or the time when Homer is composing it? but also to tell the story itself, because it is the story that first got me obsessed with Greek mythology and therefore with ancient history and therefore with history more generally. And so you could say that the Odyssey was the starting point for my own personal Odyssey, which has brought me to this point, Dominic, sitting here recording this episode with you.
所以，有一种巨大的期待感。但我认为这并不是在《不安的历史》中做《奥德赛》的唯一原因。因为老实说，这是一个我从开始做播客以来就一直想做的故事。我想稍微看看背景。它是如何被创作出来的？故事里有什么是真的吗？它是，你知道，在多大程度上可能基于事实？它可能为古代地中海的现实提供什么样的镜子，无论是奥德修斯被认为生活的时代，还是荷马创作它的时代？但也要讲述故事本身，因为正是这个故事让我第一次迷上了希腊神话，进而迷上了古代历史，进而迷上了更广泛的历史。所以你可以说《奥德赛》是我个人奥德赛的起点，它把我带到了这一点，多米尼克，坐在这里和你录制这一集。
There are tens of people wiping away tears at this already. All right, so we're going to get into the story, and we're going to try to solve some of the mysteries of the Odyssey. Now, one difference between you and Homer, I remember you saying to me when we were talking about this, is that you felt you could improve on Homer because you felt that Homer had made a mistake by not beginning at the beginning and proceeding chronologically.
已经有几十个人在擦眼泪了。好吧，我们要进入故事了，我们要试着解开《奥德赛》的一些谜团。现在，你和荷马之间的一个区别，我记得你在谈论这个时对我提起过，是你觉得你可以改进荷马，因为你觉得荷马犯了一个错误，没有从头开始并按时间顺序进行。
But you're going to take this different approach, so you're going to proceed very methodically without his haphazard approach. Am I right? Well, I like to think that if Homer were doing it as a podcast, he would do it as I'm doing. I mean, if I were writing an epic poem, of course it would be completely different, but this is a podcast. So unlike Homer, we are going to begin at the beginning and we're going to proceed through the story chronologically, which Homer does not do.
但你要采取这种不同的方法，所以你要非常系统地进行，而不是他那种随意的做法。我说的对吗？嗯，我喜欢想，如果荷马把它做成播客，他会像我这样做。我的意思是，如果我在写一部史诗，当然会完全不同，但这是一个播客。所以不像荷马，我们要从头开始，我们要按时间顺序讲述故事，而荷马并没有这样做。
And I suspect that that's the kind of aspect of the epic that Christopher Nolan will be interested in, but we will see. And to tell this story, we won't just be drawing on Homer. we will occasionally be drawing on sources outside the Iliad and the Odyssey to clarify aspects of the plot that his original listeners would have taken for granted. So let's begin right at the beginning. And for people who don't know the Odyssey, we pick up in the final moments of the Trojan War. So Troy, the great city, the greatest city in Asia, supposedly,
我怀疑这正是克里斯托弗·诺兰会感兴趣的史诗方面，但我们会看到的。为了讲述这个故事，我们不仅会借鉴荷马。我们偶尔会借鉴《伊利亚特》和《奥德赛》之外的来源，以澄清他最初的听众会认为理所当然的情节方面。所以让我们从头开始。对于那些不知道《奥德赛》的人，我们从特洛伊战争的最后时刻切入。所以特洛伊，这座伟大的城市，据说是亚洲最伟大的城市，
on the banks of the Hellespont or the Dardanelles. So if people remember the Dardanelles from a Gallipoli episode, Troy has been reduced to a smoking ruin. And the people that have done this, Tom, are the Greeks. But Homi doesn't call them the Greeks, does he? No, he calls them the Achaeans. So I think throughout these two episodes, we will be calling the Greeks, the Achaeans.
在赫勒斯滂或达达尼尔海峡的岸边。所以如果人们还记得加里波利那一集里的达达尼尔海峡，特洛伊已经被夷为冒烟的废墟。而做这件事的人，汤姆，是希腊人。但荷马并不称他们为希腊人，对吧？不，他称他们为阿开亚人。所以我认为在接下来的两集里，我们将称希腊人为阿开亚人。
That is the word that Homer uses. And the Achaeans and the Trojans have been fighting on the plain of Troy. and the Achaeans are there to seize back the kidnapped Helen, the most beautiful woman in the world, who has been stolen by Paris, the Prince of Troy, and the Trojans are fighting to keep her. And they've been doing this, as we say, for 10 years. And it looks an absolute deadlock. But then, and I'm going to quote here, a bard who features in the Odyssey, and he describes how the sons of Achaia laid the city waste after pouring out of the
这就是荷马使用的词。阿开亚人和特洛伊人在特洛伊平原上战斗。阿开亚人是为了夺回被绑架的海伦，世界上最美丽的女人，她被特洛伊王子帕里斯偷走了，而特洛伊人正在为留住她而战。正如我们所说，他们已经这样做了10年。看起来完全陷入了僵局。但随后，我要引用《奥德赛》中出现的一位吟游诗人，他描述了阿开亚人的儿子们在从……涌出后是如何将城市夷为平地的。
the horse. And the horse, of course, is the Trojan horse, the most successful wees in the whole of mythology, I would guess, in the whole history of warfare, certainly the most famous, so famous that it inspired a disastrous project in the Gallipoli invasions, didn't it? They got some ship and ran it on and it was absolute disaster. Yeah, ran it up onto the beach and then everyone shot them. However, the original Trojan horse is not a disaster. It's an absolutely crunching success. And the person who thinks it up is the man who gives his name to the Odyssey. And this is a guy called Odysseus and he is the son of Laertes. And he's the king of a very small poor island off the west coast of Greece called Ithaca. So relative to the other Achaean heroes at Troy, the other Greek
那匹马。当然，那匹马就是特洛伊木马，我想这是整个神话中最成功的诡计，在整个战争史上，当然也是最著名的，以至于它在加里波利入侵中激发了一个灾难性的项目，不是吗？他们弄了艘船，把它开上去，结果是一场彻底的灾难。是的，把它开到海滩上，然后每个人都向他们开火。然而，最初的特洛伊木马并不是一场灾难。它是一个绝对震撼的成功。而想出这个主意的人就是那个名字赋予《奥德赛》的人。这是一个叫奥德修斯的人，他是拉尔提斯的儿子。他是希腊西海岸一个非常小而贫穷的岛屿——伊萨卡岛的国王。所以相对于特洛伊的其他阿开亚英雄，其他希腊
heroes who were kings of famous golden cities like Mycini or Sparta, Odysseus is very much a kind of second division king. However, he is one of the standout stars of the Trojan War, and this is because he has qualities that enable him to transcend the poverty of his kingdom. So he's a brilliant warrior, he's famous for his courage, for his prowess on the battlefield, but he's also by far the smartest of the warriors on both sides in the Trojan War. He's very clever, he's very inventive, he's devious, he's a dab hand with a trick, with a lie. And as such, he is the particular favourite of the goddess Athena, the great warrior goddess who is simultaneously, the goddess of warfare, but also the kind of the domestic sciences and everything that kind of contributes to
英雄，他们是迈锡尼或斯巴达等著名黄金城市的国王，奥德修斯在很大程度上是一个二流国王。然而，他是特洛伊战争中的杰出明星之一，这是因为他具备使他能够超越王国贫困的品质。所以他是一位出色的战士，以勇气和在战场上的英勇而闻名，但他也是特洛伊战争双方战士中最聪明的一个。他非常聪明，非常有创造力，狡猾，是一个诡计和谎言的行家。因此，他是女神雅典娜的特别宠儿，这位伟大的女战神同时也是战争女神，但也是家政科学和所有有助于
civilization. And so she values intelligence for its own sake. And over the course of the Trojan war, she's always keeping an eye on him and occasionally appearing to to him. And she says to him, she addresses him directly, you are by far the best of all mortal men for schemes, for your way with words, while I, more than all other gods, have a name for cunning and shrewdness. And in the Odyssey, there are a number of women who fall in love with Odysseus or who are in love with Odysseus. And among those I would rank Athena. I think, you know, that there is a kind of love affair there between the mortal and the goddess. But this business about women falling in love with him is in the future, isn't it? You're doing
文明的事物的女神。所以她重视智慧本身。在特洛伊战争期间，她总是关注着他，偶尔出现在他面前。她对他说，她直接称呼他，你是所有凡人中最擅长计谋、最擅长言辞的人，而我，在所有神灵中，以狡诈和精明著称。在《奥德赛》中，有许多女性爱上了奥德修斯，或者爱着奥德修斯。在这些人中，我会把雅典娜排在前面。我想，你知道，凡人和女神之间有一种爱情故事。但关于女性爱上他的这件事是在未来，不是吗？你正在
Christopher Lone, you're flashing forward. Because, in fact, Odysseus, at this point, you know, Troy is a smoking ruin. He has only one object in mind. And that is simply to get home as quickly as possible to his wife Penelope and his son
克里斯托弗·诺兰式地闪前。因为，事实上，奥德修斯，在这一点上，你知道，特洛伊是一片冒烟的废墟。他只有一个目标。那就是尽快回到他的妻子佩涅洛佩和他的儿子
Telemachus. So his son, he hasn't seen since he was a baby, basically, or a toddler. And he's also got a dog that he's very keen on, and the dog is called Argos. Yes, who Odysseus had raised him as a puppy. Right. So talk to me about Penelope? What's Penelope like? So Penelope is obviously more important to the plot than
特勒马科斯身边。所以他的儿子，他基本上从婴儿或蹒跚学步时起就没见过。他还有一条他非常喜欢的狗，那条狗叫阿耳戈斯。是的，奥德修斯从小就把他养大。对。那么跟我说说佩涅洛佩？佩涅洛佩是什么样的人？所以佩涅洛佩显然比
Argos, the dog. So Penelope is the cousin of Helen. And Odysseus, unlike everyone else, who had gone completely mad for Helen, Odysseus had always had eyes only for Penelope. And this is because Penelope is basically very like him. She is very clever. She's very strong-minded. She's absolutely suited to him. So she's a model of what Homer calls Homer Frosine, which means kind of like-mindedness. You have a kind of similar sensibility. And Odysseus was so in love with her that prior to the departure of the Greeks for Troy,
阿耳戈斯那条狗对情节更重要。所以佩涅洛佩是海伦的表亲。而奥德修斯，不像其他人那样完全为海伦疯狂，奥德修斯一直只关注佩涅洛佩。这是因为佩涅洛佩基本上和他非常像。她非常聪明。她非常有主见。她绝对适合他。所以她是荷马所说的“Homer Frosine”的典范，意思是志同道合。你们有一种相似的感性。而奥德修斯是如此爱她，以至于在希腊人出发前往特洛伊之前，
he had actually tried to get out of having to go to the expedition. This is not in Homer, but people in ancient Greece listening to the Odyssey would have known that Odysseus' devotion to Penelope was such that he tried to pull this trick and get out of going to the war. And he's the only hero of whom such a thing, thing is recorded. So what had he done? When the Greek ambassadors, you know, summoning him to come
他实际上试图逃避参加远征。这不在荷马的作品中，但古代希腊听《奥德赛》的人会知道，奥德修斯对佩涅洛佩的忠诚使得他试图耍这个花招来逃避战争。他是唯一一个有这种记录的英雄。那么他做了什么？当希腊大使，你知道，召唤他来
to join the expedition and go to Troy with them, had arrived in Ithaca. He said, oh, I can't come. I'm mad. And they said, well, in what way are you mad? And he said, well, look at me. Here I am. I've yoked a horse and an ox and I'm plowing a beach with salt. Clearly, I'm absolutely mad. And so most of the Greek ambassadors are persuaded by this, but one of them isn't. And the nurse of Telemachus is standing nearby and has the little baby Telemichaelic. And so, and has the little baby Telemachus in her arms. But one of the ambassadors is not fooled by this. And he looks around and he sees that Telemachus's nurse is standing nearby with the baby Telemachus in her arms. And so this ambassador goes over and snatches the baby and places it in front of the horse and ox as
参加远征并和他们一起去特洛伊时，已经到达了伊萨卡。他说，哦，我不能去。我疯了。他们说，好吧，你哪方面疯了？他说，好吧，看看我。我在这儿。我套了一匹马和一头牛，正在用盐耕海滩。显然，我绝对疯了。所以大多数希腊大使都被说服了，但其中一个没有。特勒马科斯的保姆站在附近，抱着小婴儿特勒马科斯。但是其中一位大使并没有被这个骗过。他环顾四周，看到特勒马科斯的保姆站在附近，怀里抱着小婴儿特勒马科斯。于是这位大使走过去，抢过婴儿，把它放在马和牛的前面，因为
Odysseus is driving them along the beach. And what's Odysseus going to do? He has the choice. He can either drive across the little baby, kill it, but not have to go to Troy or swerve and reveal that he's not actually mad and so he opts to swerve and not kill his baby son and he's rumbled and so he duly has to leave for Troy and he sets sail at the head of a fleet of 12 ships and homer in the Iliad describes their prowls flashing crimson and he's there for the 10 years he fights heroically he comes up with the wheeze of the Trojan horse Troy falls Odysseus takes lots of loot he's ready to go back home him and his 12 ships and so off they sail.
奥德修斯正赶着它们沿着海滩走。奥德修斯会怎么做？他有选择。他要么可以赶着马车压过小婴儿，杀了他，但不必去特洛伊，要么转向，揭示他其实并没有疯，所以他选择转向，不杀他的婴儿儿子，他被识破了，所以他不得不按时离开去特洛伊，他率领一支由12艘船组成的舰队起航，荷马在《伊利亚特》中描述它们的船头闪烁着深红色，他在那里待了10年，英勇作战，他想出了特洛伊木马的诡计，特洛伊陷落，奥德修斯拿了很多战利品，他准备回家了，他和他的12艘船，于是他们起航了。
Right, but the journey home is not quite as simple as the journey there, is it? That is putting it mildly. Right. And this is partly because they keep getting distracted and they're distracted right from the very start. So they set off, the winds blow them west from Troy. They're going along the northern kind of coastline of the Aegean and they arrive at a place called Ismarus.
对，但回家的旅程不像去那里的旅程那么简单，是吗？这话说得轻了。对。这部分是因为他们不断分心，而且从一开始就分心了。所以他们出发了，风把他们从特洛伊向西吹。他们沿着爱琴海的北部海岸线航行，到达了一个叫伊斯马罗斯的地方。
And there, instead of sort of putting ashore for supplies, shaking hands with the harbour master, exchanging pleasantries with the burgers of the town, Odysseus, by some standards, behaves very poorly. Well, he has something of the Viking about him. I think it's fair to say. So here is Odysseus talking about what he did at Ismarus. I laid waste the city and killed the men after dragging their wives from the city with a great
在那里，奥德修斯没有靠岸补给、与港务长握手、与镇上的市民寒暄，而是按照某些标准，表现得非常糟糕。嗯，他身上有某种维京人的特质。我想说这是公平的。所以这是奥德修斯谈论他在伊斯马罗斯所做的事情。我夷平了这座城市，在把他们的妻子从城市中拖出来后杀死了男人，还有大量的
deal of booty as well. And it's fair to say that neither Homer nor any ancient source of which I am aware mentions what happens to these women that Odysseus and his men have kind of dragged off into slavery. I mean, do they die on the voyage? I mean, what are they sold? I mean, we just don't know. Nothing good. Nothing good, I think. One man in Ismarus is spared, and this is a guy called Maron, who is a priest of the god Apollo, and his family is spared as well. And Maron, to show his gratitude for this gives Odysseus seven bars of gold, a silver mixing bowl, and 12 amphorae of wine. and this wine is described as being sweet and undiluted, a drink for the gods.
战利品。公平地说，荷马或我所知的任何古代文献都没有提到这些被奥德修斯和他的手下拖去当奴隶的女性后来怎么样了。我的意思是，她们在航行中死了吗？我的意思是，她们被卖了吗？我的意思是，我们只是不知道。没什么好事。没什么好事，我想。在伊斯马罗斯，有一个人幸免于难，这是一个叫马隆的人，他是太阳神阿波罗的祭司，他的家人也幸免于难。马隆为了表达感激之情，给了奥德修斯七根金条、一个银制调酒碗和12安弗拉酒。这种酒被描述为甜美且未稀释，是神灵的饮品。
And we mentioned this in our episode on the history of wine. It's a kind of ancient Greek premier grand crew. It is incredibly strong. And Maron suggests to Odysseus that one portion of this wine should be mixed with 19 portions of water. And that anyone who drinks it neat is obviously the most monstrous barbarian. So that is just something for listeners. to bear in mind. And Odysseus, you know, he's pleased with all this.
我们在关于葡萄酒历史的那一集中提到过这一点。这是一种古希腊的顶级佳酿。它非常烈。马隆建议奥德修斯，这种酒的一份应该与19份水混合。任何喝纯酒的人显然都是最野蛮的野蛮人。所以这只是给听众提个醒。而奥德修斯，你知道，他对这一切很满意。
He's ready to head off. But again, this is a theme that will recur throughout the Odyssey and indeed these episodes. His men, when he says, right, let's crack on, they've got stuck into the wine and they've also having a barbecue. Hence the Russell Crow voice for the beginning, because there's something very Australian about Odysseus's crew. I mean, basically, wherever they stop, they have barbecues and start grilling meat on the beach. And that's a terrible thing to do.
他准备出发了。但同样，这是一个将在整个《奥德赛》甚至这些剧集中反复出现的主题。当他说，好吧，我们出发吧，他的手下已经沉迷于酒，而且还在烧烤。这就是为什么开头用了罗素·克劳的声音，因为奥德修斯的船员身上有一种非常澳大利亚的感觉。我的意思是，基本上，无论他们在哪里停下来，他们都会烧烤，开始在海滩上烤肉。这真是一件可怕的事情。
It is because it enables the locals who've been beaten off to kind of rally and return to the attack with much larger numbers of men. And so Odysseus and his men find themselves horribly outnumbered. They form a shield wall. But as the sun sets on the scene of battle, they're forced to retreat onto their ships. And they manage to escape essentially by the skin of their teeth. And over 70 of his men are left dead. So already the expedition is starting to leach manpower. However, they get away, they sail southwards across the Aegean.
确实如此，因为它使那些被打败的当地人能够集结起来，并以更多的人数发动反击。所以奥德修斯和他的手下发现自己处于极度劣势。他们组成了盾墙。但当太阳在战场上落下时，他们被迫撤退到船上。他们基本上是死里逃生。他有70多名手下战死。所以远征队已经开始流失人力了。然而，他们逃脱了，向南穿过爱琴海。
They round the southernmost tip of Greece and the southernmost tip of the Peloponnese, Cape Malia. And now all Odysseus has to do is kind of steer around the Cape, head northwards, go around the kind of the edge of the Peloponnese, and there is Ithaca waiting for him. But disaster, because as they round the Cape, a violent storm blows up, terrible winds, blow them and blow them and blow them. They rage for nine days and nights. And when the nine days and nights of wind finally calms down, they got no idea where they are. And on the 10th day, they see land and they moor there. And Odysseus sends a couple of scouts to go up the beach,
他们绕过希腊的最南端和伯罗奔尼撒半岛的最南端，马利亚角。现在奥德修斯所要做的就是绕过海角，向北航行，绕过伯罗奔尼撒半岛的边缘，伊萨卡就在那里等着他。但灾难发生了，因为当他们绕过海角时，一场猛烈的风暴刮了起来，可怕的风，吹着他们，吹着他们，吹着他们。它们肆虐了九天九夜。当九天九夜的风终于平静下来时，他们根本不知道自己在哪里。在第10天，他们看到了陆地，并在那里停泊。奥德修斯派了几个侦察兵去海滩，
head inland and try and work out where they are. And then he sits there and he waits for them to return, but they don't come back. And so finally he thinks, well, I better go and work out what's going on here. And so he leaves the ship, follows their footsteps, so you know, he can trek them up the beach. Goes inland and he finds them and they are kind of, they're half asleep. They're all blissed out.
向内陆走去，试图弄清楚他们在哪里。然后他坐在那里等着他们回来，但他们没有回来。所以最后他想，好吧，我最好去弄清楚这里发生了什么。于是他离开船，沿着他们的足迹走，这样他就能在海滩上追踪他们。向内陆走去，他找到了他们，他们有点，他们半睡半醒。他们都飘飘欲仙。
They've got a kind of spaced look on their faces, smiling happily. And he tries to kind of rouse them, tells them, come on, we've got to get cracking. And they don't want to move. And finally, he uses force. He kind of physically drags them. And they start to sob. They just want to stay there and chillax and, you know, have fun and be mellow. and not go kind of roaring off around the world.
他们的脸上有一种恍惚的表情，开心地笑着。他试图唤醒他们，告诉他们，来吧，我们得出发了。他们不想动。最后，他使用了武力。他把他们拖走了。他们开始啜泣。他们只想待在那里放松，你知道，玩得开心，变得柔和。而不是在世界各地咆哮。
They can't be asked to go home. They don't want to. They're enjoying themselves too much where they are. And Odysseus realises where they are. They have come to the land of the lotus eaters. And Homer explains what this means. Now, whichever of them ate the honey, sweet fruit of the lotus, no longer had any desire to send word of themselves or return.
他们不想回家。他们不想。他们在那里玩得太开心了。奥德修斯意识到他们在哪里。他们来到了食莲人的土地。荷马解释了这意味着什么。现在，无论他们中谁吃了莲花的蜂蜜甜果，都不再有任何发送关于自己的消息或返回的欲望。
And so Odysseus is aware that if all his crew get out and start munching on the lotus, They will never return home. And so he orders his fleet to leave immediately because they can't risk losing that, you know, the will for the Nostos, the will for the return home. So let's just stop the story right there and ask what this is all about. So what do people think the land of the lotus eaters refers to? Is there something in, I don't know, Bronze Age history or something that would, that it is the genesis of this idea? I mean, it's a question that the Greeks themselves asked. So Herodotus, the first historian, he worked out that the land of the lotus eaters must have been on the North African coast because the winds had been blowing Odysseus in that direction.
所以奥德修斯意识到，如果他所有的船员都出去开始咀嚼莲花，他们将永远不会回家。于是他命令他的舰队立即离开，因为他们不能冒失去那个，你知道，对“Nostos”的渴望，对回家的渴望的风险。所以让我们就在这里停下故事，问问这是怎么回事。那么人们认为食莲人的土地指的是什么？在青铜时代历史或其他什么东西中有什么东西是这个想法的起源吗？我的意思是，这是一个希腊人自己问的问题。所以希罗多德，第一位历史学家，他算出食莲人的土地一定在北非海岸，因为风一直把奥德修斯吹向那个方向。
So this is just kind of due south of Sicily. Victorian scholars thought that probably it was opium. And I think this probably says more about the Victorians than it does about Homer because it was a great age for opium dens. But it's a very kind of popular idea. There are other theories which I was kind of looking up for this episode. Apparently there's a small tree called the Zizifus Lotus, but the problem with that is it's not narcotic. And there is apparently a blue lotus,
所以这就在西西里岛的正南方。维多利亚时代的学者认为这可能是鸦片。我认为这可能比荷马更能说明维多利亚时代的人，因为那是鸦片馆的黄金时代。但这是一种非常流行的想法。还有其他理论，我为这一集查过。显然有一种小树叫枣莲，但问题是它没有麻醉作用。显然还有一种蓝莲花，
which does have psychotropic properties. So maybe it's that. I don't know. I'm not a specialist in the flora of North Africa. It's more likely, surely, that this is a literary symbol, the lotus needing, no, that it's basically about losing yourself
它确实有精神药物特性。所以也许是那个。我不知道。我不是北非植物学的专家。更有可能的是，这肯定是一个文学符号，吃莲花，不，它基本上是关于迷失自我
and losing sight of your goal. I mean, I think it's important for the whole structure of the poem that you have to completely believe in Odysseus' desperation to get back home and that his men share in that desperation. And so in a way, the best way to kind of highlight that is to show the alternative what that would mean. And essentially it just means kind of chilling out and doing nothing, which might have its appeal.
和失去目标。我的意思是，我认为这对整首诗的结构很重要，你必须完全相信奥德修斯回家的绝望，并且他的手下也分享这种绝望。所以从某种意义上说，强调这一点的最好方法是展示替代方案，那意味着什么。而本质上它只是意味着放松和无所事事，这可能有它的吸引力。
But ultimately, it's seen as a danger. And so when Odysseus pushes off from the land of the Lotus, eaters. The reader or the listener can feel confident that this is a man utterly committed to getting back home. And this is very important because all kinds of obstacles, as we will see, are going to be waiting for him on his journey back. Well, let's get to the next obstacle, which is the most famous obstacle of all. So they set off, don't they? They reach another bit of land. So this is a little island. As far as they can tell, the island is inhabited only by wild goats. they have another barbecue inevitably.
但最终，它被视为一种危险。所以当奥德修斯离开食莲人的土地时。读者或听众可以确信，这是一个完全致力于回家的人。这非常重要，因为正如我们将看到的，他的回乡之旅将会有各种各样的障碍等着他。好吧，让我们进入下一个障碍，这是所有障碍中最著名的一个。所以他们出发了，不是吗？他们到达了另一块陆地。所以这是一个小岛。据他们所知，岛上只居住着野山羊。他们不可避免地又烧烤了。
Another Barbie. And they see that there's a larger island nearby. And on this island they can see smoke rising into the sky. So that's an interesting and exciting and tantalizing sign. And Odysseus, he goes off on his own. Am I right to find out what's on this island? There's smoke, but there's no sign of agriculture, which is a puzzle, because they would assume that a kind of a settlement people would be telling fields,
又一次烧烤。他们看到附近有一个更大的岛屿。在这个岛上，他们可以看到烟雾升向天空。所以这是一个有趣、令人兴奋和诱人的迹象。奥德修斯，他独自一人去了。我说的对吗，去看看岛上有什么？有烟，但没有农业的迹象，这是一个谜，因为他们会认为某种定居点的人会耕种田地，
but there's no sign of that. And so Odysseus is a little bit, a little bit, nervous about this, not sure what that might portend. And so he sets sail in a single ship. So he leaves the other 11 ships kind of hidden off the smaller island. He goes off, he crosses over to the main island, they land
但没有那种迹象。所以奥德修斯有点，有点，对此感到紧张，不确定这可能预示着什么。于是他乘一艘船起航。所以他把其他11艘船藏在较小的岛屿附近。他走了，他穿过海峡到达主岛，他们登陆
and they walk along the beach and they see a cave. And the entrance to this cave is kind of, it's walled off with a kind of stone wall. So he thinks, well, this is obviously signs of habitation. And so he decides to investigate and
他们沿着海滩走，看到一个洞穴。这个洞穴的入口被某种石墙围起来了。所以他想，好吧，这显然是有人居住的迹象。于是他决定调查，
he takes his 12 bravest men with him, and he also takes with him a goat skin filled with that delicious, very strong wine that had been given to him by Maron, the priest of Apollo. And they go up to the cave and they call out and there's no answer. And so they decide to kind of wander in and investigate. And they find that it's empty except for lambs and for kids who are in pens. And there are racks and racks of cheeses. So clearly there is someone living here. And Odysseus decides to wait for the owner of the cave to return.
他带着他12个最勇敢的人，还带着一个装满马隆（阿波罗祭司）给他的那种美味、非常烈酒的羊皮袋。他们走到洞穴前，大声呼喊，但没有回答。于是他们决定走进去调查。他们发现里面除了羊圈里的羔羊和幼崽外空无一人。还有一排排的奶酪。所以显然有人住在这里。奥德修斯决定等洞穴的主人回来。
And they build a fire and they grill some cheese. And it's like a kind of, I suppose, a kind of Mediterranean hiking holiday or something like that. Again, it's this kind of Aussie style obsession with having barbecues at inappropriate moments. They're laid out having this barbecue and outside the sun is setting. And towards dusk, the earth starts to shake. So it's a little bit like the scene in Jurassic Park when the glass of water on the Jeep starts to shake. And it's not a Tyrannosaur that appears, but a monstrous giant human figure. And he is driving flocks of sheep and goats ahead of him.
他们生了火，烤了一些奶酪。这就像某种，我想，某种地中海徒步旅行度假之类的。同样，这又是那种在不适当的时候烧烤的澳洲式痴迷。他们躺在那里烧烤，外面太阳正在下山。黄昏时分，大地开始震动。所以这有点像《侏罗纪公园》里吉普车上的水杯开始震动的那一幕。出现的不是霸王龙，而是一个巨大的怪物人类形象。他赶着羊群和山羊走在他前面。
And he enters the cave. And as he enters the cave, he blocks out the light. As the eyes of the Achaeans adjust, they look up into his face and they see that he has only a single. eye. So this is a cyclops and it's a cyclops by the name of Polyphemus. And Polyphemus is of immense size and therefore strength and he picks up a giant boulder and uses it to seal the entrance. It would be completely impossible for Odysseus and his men to move it. And then he looks around with his single eye and he spots Odysseus and his men cowering at the back of the cave and he demands to know who they are. And just to be, just to check, do they know what he is? Do they have a sense of him? Or is he something they've never heard of and never seen before?
他进入了洞穴。当他进入洞穴时，他挡住了光线。当阿开亚人的眼睛适应后，他们抬头看着他的脸，看到他只有一个。眼睛。所以这是一个独眼巨人，他的名字叫波吕斐摩斯。波吕斐摩斯体型巨大，因此力量也很大，他捡起一块巨大的巨石，用它封住了入口。奥德修斯和他的手下完全不可能移动它。然后他用他那只独眼环顾四周，发现了蜷缩在洞穴深处的奥德修斯和他的手下，他要求知道他们是谁。为了确认一下，他们知道他是什么吗？他们对他有了解吗？还是他是一个他们从未听说过也从未见过的人？
I think the general vibe is that he's not good news. Okay. He's enormous, he's fierce looking, he's got a single eye. I don't think that this is the kind of person that you probably want to run into when you've been grilling his cheese. But he's hopeful that perhaps he could get this guy on his side. And so he conquers his fear and he steps forward and he introduces himself. He introduces himself. He introduces himself. as an Achaon, but he doesn't really give any more detail. And when Polyphemus asks Odysseus, you know, well, where is your ship? Odysseus lies and says that they've lost it in a storm. He loves a fib. He doesn't want to give away too much, because he is clearly nervous about whether Polyphemus is the kind of person you want, within whose cave you want to be stuck. And when Polyphemus learns that their ship has been sunk, he reaches for two of Odysseus's men, smashes out their brains on the floor, devours them, falls asleep, stretched out among his flocks. So there, Dominic, is your answer. He's not good news. He's not the kind of person you want to be stuck in a cave with.
我认为总体的感觉是他不是什么好东西。好吧。他巨大，看起来凶猛，有一只眼睛。我不认为当你烤了他的奶酪时，这是你可能想遇到的人。但他希望也许能把这家伙拉到自己这边。于是他克服了恐惧，走上前去，介绍了自己。他介绍了自己。他介绍了自己。作为一名阿开亚人，但他并没有真正提供更多细节。当波吕斐摩斯问奥德修斯，你知道，好吧，你的船在哪里？奥德修斯撒谎说他们在风暴中失去了它。他喜欢编造。他不想透露太多，因为他显然很紧张，不知道波吕斐摩斯是否是你想要困在他洞穴里的那种人。当波吕斐摩斯得知他们的船沉没时，他伸手抓住了奥德修斯的两个手下，把他们的脑袋砸在地板上，吞食了他们，然后睡着了，躺在他的羊群中。所以，多米尼克，这就是你的答案。他不是什么好东西。他不是那种你想被困在洞穴里的人。
He's blocked them in the cave with a boulder, which is crucial. So they can't just kill him because they wouldn't be able to move the boulder, right? Exactly so. So they have no choice but to pass this completely miserable night. And in due course, as Homer puts it, morning-born dawn touches the sky with her rosy fingertips. Polyphemus wakes up and for breakfast he has two more of Odysseus's men. You know, he smashes them again on the kind of the side of the wall and devours them. And then he moves the boulder, drives out his flocks and then seals the cave up again with the boulder. So again, you know, Odysseus and his men are stuck there. So, you know, what are they going to do now? This seems an impossible situation. But Odysseus, fortunately, you know, he is blindingly smart.
他用一块巨石把他们堵在洞穴里，这很关键。所以他们不能直接杀了他，因为他们无法移动巨石，对吧？正是如此。所以他们别无选择，只能度过这个极其悲惨的夜晚。正如荷马所说，晨生的黎明用她玫瑰色的指尖触碰天空。波吕斐摩斯醒来，早餐吃了奥德修斯的另外两个手下。你知道，他再次把他们砸在墙边，吞食了他们。然后他移开巨石，赶出他的羊群，然后再次用巨石封住洞穴。所以同样，你知道，奥德修斯和他的手下被困在那里。所以，你知道，他们现在该怎么办？这似乎是一个不可能的情况。但奥德修斯，幸运的是，你知道，他聪明得惊人。
And so he looks around and he realizes that there is a possible way out because polyphemus has got a club. And this club is enormous. It's kind of like the size of the trunk of an enormous tree, the length and scale of a the mast of a ship. So Odysseus gets his men to whittle this club down to a very, very sharp point. And then when they've done that, they conceal it under kind of sheepskins or whatever. And when Polyphemus returns that evening, he devours two more men.
所以他环顾四周，意识到有一个可能的出路，因为波吕斐摩斯有一根棍子。这根棍子巨大。它有点像一棵巨大树的树干，长度和规模就像一艘船的桅杆。所以奥德修斯让他的手下把这根棍子削成一个非常非常尖的尖端。然后当他们做完后，他们把它藏在羊皮或其他什么东西下面。当波吕斐摩斯那天晚上回来时，他吞食了另外两个人。
Odysseus steps forward and he offers Polyphemus a cup of Maron's delicious and did I mention it's very strong wine. They brought the wine with them, crucial. And Polyphemus is clearly a barbarian because he does not water it down. Instead, he guzzles it down neat. And then when Odysseus comes forward and offers him another two cups of this wine, he guzzles that down as well. And once he's had these three cups of wine,
奥德修斯走上前，给波吕斐摩斯倒了一杯马隆的美味，我提到过它非常烈吗，酒。他们随身带了酒，这很关键。波吕斐摩斯显然是个野蛮人，因为他没有稀释它。相反，他直接大口喝下。然后当奥德修斯走上前又给他倒了两杯这种酒时，他也大口喝下了。一旦他喝了这三杯酒，
He asks Odysseus for his name. And Odysseus does not give his real name. Instead, he says, my name is Utis, which means in Greek, no one. Oh, so clever. And Polyphemus says, well, you know, as a thank you for the wine, here is what I'm going to do. I will eat you last. Ah, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. Great giant laugh.
他问奥德修斯的名字。奥德修斯没有说出他的真名。相反，他说，我的名字是“Utis”，在希腊语中意思是“没有人”。哦，太聪明了。波吕斐摩斯说，好吧，你知道，作为对酒的感谢，这就是我要做的。我会最后一个吃你。啊，哈，哈，哈，哈，哈。巨大的巨人笑声。
He then falls asleep. And as he falls asleep, he kind of belches and vomits up wine and. bits of hand and bits of flesh, and it all spews out onto the floor of the cave, and Polyphemus kind of rolls over, vomits up a bit more, and then he's flat out, and he's snoring, and the cave echoes to the sound of the snores. And this is the chance that Odysseus has been waiting for. So he and his men, remember, have got this club, which they've sharpened into a spike, and they heat this giant spike in the fire, and then they clamber up.
然后他睡着了。当他睡着时，他打了个嗝，呕吐出酒和。手和肉的碎片，这一切都喷到了洞穴的地板上，波吕斐摩斯翻了个身，又呕吐出一点，然后他彻底瘫倒了，他打着呼噜，洞穴里回荡着呼噜声。这就是奥德修斯一直在等待的机会。所以他和他的手下，记住，有这根棍子，他们已经把它削成了尖刺，他们把这根巨大的尖刺在火中加热，然后他们爬上
the body of the sleeping cyclops and they aim it over his single eye point rests on the lid Odysseus gives the signal and then it's driven deep into the eye of the cyclops and to quote Homer his eyelids and his brows were blistered all round by the blast
睡着的独眼巨人的身体，他们把它对准他那只独眼，尖端落在眼睑上，奥德修斯发出信号，然后它被深深地刺入独眼巨人的眼睛，引用荷马的话，他的眼睑和眉毛都被爆炸灼伤了
as the eyeball burned its roots crackling in the fire and understandably Polyphemus screams and howls he pulls the spike out of his eye and hurls it against the side of the cave and starts bellowing for help. And there are other cyclops, you know, his neighbors, and they hear his cries, and they come down
当眼球燃烧时，它的根部在火中噼啪作响，可以理解的是，波吕斐摩斯尖叫和嚎叫。他把尖刺从眼睛里拔出来，扔向洞穴的一侧，开始大声呼救。还有其他的独眼巨人，你知道，他的邻居，他们听到了他的哭声，他们下来了
and they ask him what has happened. And again, to quote Homer, from inside the cave, mighty Polyphemus made his reply, friends, no one is killing me. And so his friends answer, well, if no one is killing you, if no one has harmed you, and it's clearly then just a malady sent by Zeus, you must pray to your divine father for relief. And Polyphemus's divine father is Poseidon, the God of the sea, so a very, very powerful God indeed. Not good news if you want to get home by sea, right? I mean, to have Poseidon against you. Absolutely.
并问他发生了什么事。同样，引用荷马的话，从洞穴里面，强大的波吕斐摩斯回答说，朋友们，没有人正在杀我。所以他的朋友们回答说，好吧，如果没有人正在杀你，如果没有人伤害你，那显然只是宙斯降下的疾病，你必须向你的神圣父亲祈求救济。而波吕斐摩斯的父亲是波塞冬，海神，所以确实是一个非常非常强大的神。如果你想通过海路回家，这可不是什么好消息，对吧？我的意思是，让波塞冬与你为敌。绝对是。
So, brilliant from Odysseus. He's come up with the, you know, with the spike in the eye wheeze. And also the whole, you know, calling himself, nobody means that the other cyclops think that nothing's the matter with Polyphemus. But they're still not out of danger. Because what Polyphemus does now is to push back the, um, the boulder because he's got to let his flocks of, of sheep and goats go out. And as they kind of start milling out through the cave entrance, he feels each one to make sure that Odysseus and his men aren't trying to kind of creep out hidden among the flocks.
奥德修斯真是太聪明了。他想出了那个刺瞎眼睛的妙计。还有，他自称“无人”，让其他独眼巨人以为波吕斐摩斯没事。但他们还没脱离危险。因为波吕斐摩斯现在要把那块巨石推开，因为他得让他的羊群和山羊出去。当它们开始从洞口挤出来时，他摸了每一只羊，以确保奥德修斯和他的手下没有藏在羊群里溜出来。
But again, Odysseus is equal to this challenge. So what he does is he ties each of his men underneath the belly of a sheep. And they all kind of managed to get out and Polyphemus doesn't realize that they're kind of tied under the bellies of the sheep. And then he himself, there's one giant ram and he hugs on to the fleece of the fleece of the sheep. this giant ram and the ram trots out. And Polyphemus, he strokes the ram and realizes that this is, you know, his beloved ram and feels that it's walking slowly because of the weight. But he thinks that the ram is walking slowly out of grief for his blinded master.
但奥德修斯再次应对了这个挑战。他把每个手下都绑在羊的肚子下面。他们都设法逃了出来，波吕斐摩斯并没有意识到他们被绑在羊肚子下面。至于他自己，有一只巨大的公羊，他紧紧抱住那只公羊的羊毛，公羊小跑着出去了。波吕斐摩斯抚摸着公羊，意识到这是他心爱的公羊，并感觉到它因为重量而走得很慢。但他以为公羊走得慢是因为为失明的主人感到悲伤。
So very sad. Anyway, Odysseus and his men managed, therefore, to get out of the cave, cut themselves free from the sheep. They drive the entire flock of sheep down towards their ship. They load the sheep onto the boat so that they can kind of roast them later and have another barbecue and then they pull out to sea. But Odysseus is a warrior and he wants the person he's defeated to know who has vanquished him. And so he taunts the blinded cyclops from his ship as it's pulling out. And Polyphemus is so furious that he kind of gropes for the top of a mountain and pulls the summit off and hurls the rock in the direction of Adiomis.
真是太悲伤了。总之，奥德修斯和他的手下因此成功逃出了洞穴，解开了身上的束缚。他们把整群羊赶向他们的船。他们把羊装上船，以便以后烤着吃，再来一次烧烤，然后他们驶向大海。但奥德修斯是一位战士，他希望被他击败的人知道是谁打败了他。于是，当船驶离时，他从船上嘲讽那个失明的独眼巨人。波吕斐摩斯愤怒至极，他摸索着山顶，把山峰拔了下来，朝奥德修斯的方向扔去。
And it lands just in front of Odysseus's ship. And there's a great tsunami and it washes Odysseus's ship back towards the shore. And it looks like they're going to be shipwrecked on it. So Odysseus takes a pole and it's kind of like a punt, you know, trying to kind of push it off the side of the river. So he pushes their ship back out to sea. He and his men row frantically. And then again, he cannot help himself. And he stands on the rear of the ship and he yells taunts at Polyphemus again and fatally
石头落在了奥德修斯船的前面。引发了一场巨大的海啸，把奥德修斯的船冲回了岸边。看起来他们要在那儿遇难了。于是奥德修斯拿了一根杆子，就像撑船一样，试图把它从河边推开。他把船推回了大海。他和手下拼命划船。然后，他又忍不住了。他站在船尾，再次对波吕斐摩斯大声嘲讽，并致命地
reveals his true identity. He announces himself as Odysseus Saka of Cities, the son of Laertes, who holds his home in Ithaca. And when Polyphemus hears this, he gives a great groan, and he raises his arms, and he prays to Poseidon, the god of the sea, his divine father. Hear me, Poseidon, earth, shaker, you of the deep blue mane, grant that Odysseus Sacker of cities may never reach his home, that son of Laertes who holds his home in Ithaca. But if his fate is to see his loved ones once more and make it back home to his strong-built palace and to the land of his fathers,
暴露了自己的真实身份。他宣布自己是“劫掠城市的奥德修斯”，拉尔提斯的儿子，家在伊萨卡。当波吕斐摩斯听到这些时，他发出一声巨大的呻吟，举起双臂，向他的神圣父亲——海神波塞冬祈祷。听我说，波塞冬，大地的震撼者，深蓝鬃毛的主人，让劫掠城市的奥德修斯永远无法回到他的家，那个家在伊萨卡的拉尔提斯的儿子。但如果他的命运是再次见到他的亲人，并回到他那坚固的宫殿和祖先的土地，
then let him come late and hapless after losing all his comrades on a ship that is not his own and may he find trouble at home. That bodes very ill for Odysseus, if Poseidon hears his son's prayer. And if Poseidon does hear that prayer, of course, then Odysseus's prospects of getting back to Ithaca with all of his men are hanging in the balance. And we'll find out what happens next after the break.
那就让他迟迟归来，孤苦伶仃，在失去所有同伴后，乘坐一艘不属于他自己的船，愿他在家中遭遇不幸。如果波塞冬听到了他儿子的祈祷，这对奥德修斯来说是非常不祥的预兆。如果波塞冬真的听到了那个祈祷，那么奥德修斯带着所有手下回到伊萨卡的希望就悬而未决了。休息之后，我们将揭晓接下来会发生什么。
This episode is brought to you by Hamilton the musical. Tom, when we think of America's founding fathers, we think of dusty portraits, grim-faced men with terrible teeth, and of course, unpaid tax bills, don't we? That's right, but what we don't see is the struggle, the resentment, the euphoria, the love, the rapping, all in the name of American Independence 250 years ago. That's what we loved, isn't it, about Lynn Manuel Miranda's award-winning musical Hamilton, which we went to see with our team just the other day. It brought the story of those turbulent years to life beyond the walls of a museum from the room where it happened. It's an incredible depiction of the life and legacy of Alexander Hamilton,
本集由音乐剧《汉密尔顿》赞助播出。汤姆，当我们想到美国的开国元勋时，我们会想到尘封的肖像、表情严峻、牙齿糟糕的男人们，当然还有未付的税单，不是吗？没错，但我们没看到的是250年前为了美国独立而进行的斗争、怨恨、狂喜、爱和说唱。这就是我们喜欢林-曼努埃尔·米兰达的获奖音乐剧《汉密尔顿》的原因，不是吗？我们前几天和团队一起去看了。它让那些动荡岁月的历史故事在博物馆的围墙之外鲜活起来，就在那间发生故事的房间里。这是对亚历山大·汉密尔顿生平和遗产的精彩描绘，
who was George Washington's right-hand man, an incredibly politically significant figure. It is an absolute cultural phenomenon, and you can experience it right now at London's Victoria Palace Theatre. Book tickets today at hamiltonmusical.com forward slash London. Hey, this is Michael and Hannah from Gollhangers The Rest is Science. This episode is brought to you by Cancer Research UK. Or if your immune system could learn to recognize cancer cells. That's immunotherapy. One type is car T cell therapy.
他是乔治·华盛顿的得力助手，是一位极具政治影响力的人物。这绝对是一个文化现象，你现在就可以在伦敦的维多利亚宫剧院体验它。今天就在 hamiltonmusical.com/London 预订门票。嘿，我是来自《其余皆科学》的迈克尔和汉娜。本集由英国癌症研究中心赞助。如果你的免疫系统能学会识别癌细胞会怎样？这就是免疫疗法。其中一种是CAR-T细胞疗法。
T cells are your body's watchman, and doctors can now extract these and reprogram them to spot cancer. Car T cells, they've started showing this real promise in treating cancers of the blood like leukemia. Because unlike most cancers, blood cancer cells, they float around separately, and that makes it easier for car T cells to seek them out and destroy them. And now, Cancer Research UK-funded scientists are designing CAR-T cells that can tackle solid tumors too, making them tougher so they can survive a more crowded and hostile cancer environment. Now, these approaches are experimental, but they do start to show where treatment might go next. And over the past 50 years, Cancer Research UK's pioneering work has helped to double cancer survival in the UK. I mean, this shows you how far research can take us.
T细胞是你身体的守望者，医生现在可以提取这些细胞并重新编程，让它们发现癌症。CAR-T细胞在治疗白血病等血液癌症方面展现出了真正的希望。因为与大多数癌症不同，血癌细胞是单独漂浮的，这使得CAR-T细胞更容易找到并摧毁它们。现在，英国癌症研究中心资助的科学家们正在设计能够应对实体瘤的CAR-T细胞，使它们更强韧，以便在更拥挤、更恶劣的癌症环境中生存。现在，这些方法还处于实验阶段，但它们确实开始展示治疗的未来方向。在过去的50年里，英国癌症研究中心的开创性工作帮助英国的癌症存活率翻了一番。我的意思是，这向你展示了研究能带我们走多远。
For more information about Cancer Research UK, their research, breakthroughs, and how you can support them, visit cancer researchuk.org forward slash rest is science. Hey, y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair. Wayfair, every style, every home. Welcome back to The Rest is history. So our hero Odysseus has been swept by gay. and storms far from the familiar waters of Greece and the Aegean.
有关英国癌症研究中心、他们的研究、突破以及你如何支持他们的更多信息，请访问 cancerresearchuk.org/restisscience。嘿，大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森，代表Wayfair。有没有在网上订购过家具并想过“如果……会怎样”？比如，如果它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你应该从Wayfair订购。在Wayfair，没有“如果”。只有你喜欢的风格和你可以信赖的质量。访问Wayfair。Wayfair，每种风格，每个家。欢迎回到《其余皆历史》。所以我们的英雄奥德修斯被风暴吹离了希腊和爱琴海熟悉的航道。
And he has ended up in a very mysterious and murky dimension, a place where people are off their faces on narcotic lotuses, where one-eyed, monstrous giants are dashing people's brains out and having them for breakfast. Now, to the original listeners of this story, because people would have listened to it, that have heard it rather than read it, I think. Would they have seen these adventures? I mean, is this the stuff of fairy tales and fantasy? Or did they think these things really happened?
他最终进入了一个非常神秘和阴暗的维度，一个人们沉迷于麻醉莲花的地方，一个独眼的怪物巨人把人摔碎脑浆当作早餐的地方。现在，对于这个故事的最初听众来说，因为人们是听而不是读这个故事的，我想。他们会看到这些冒险吗？我的意思是，这是童话和幻想的内容吗？还是他们认为这些事情真的发生了？
I mean, on one level, obviously, it is fantasy. But there was a sense that these islands could be located in the geography of the Mediterranean Sea. So we've heard that Herodotus, the first great historian, he located the land of the lotus eaters in North Africa. And there was a tradition as well, among the... Greeks that the cave of Polyphemus had lain beneath Mount Etna in Sicily. And Etna, of course, is a volcano. So there is a sense of fire hidden in the mountain. And the story was that the cyclops used these fires of Etna to forge the thunderbolts that they then gave to Zeus and that Polyphemus is one of these cyclops that were working on the thunderbolts. There is a brilliant theory about
我的意思是，从一个层面来看，这显然是幻想。但有一种感觉，这些岛屿可以在地中海的地理位置上找到。所以我们听说希罗多德，第一位伟大的历史学家，他把食莲人的土地定位在北非。在希腊人中也有一个传统，认为波吕斐摩斯的洞穴位于西西里的埃特纳火山之下。当然，埃特纳是一座火山。所以山中隐藏着火的感觉。故事是说独眼巨人利用埃特纳的这些火来锻造他们随后交给宙斯的雷霆，而波吕斐摩斯就是这些锻造雷霆的独眼巨人之一。有一个绝妙的理论关于
why one-eye giants might have been identified with Sicily. So there's a wonderful book by a palentologist called Adrian Mayer, who's written about what the ancients thought ancient fossils were. And she suggested that there were dwarf elephants on Sicily, so they'd gone extinct long before ancient Greek times. But their skulls might have been discovered. And because you have, you know, you have the trunk, the nasal cavity, if you look at the skull of an elephant,
为什么独眼巨人可能与西西里有关。所以有一本由古生物学家阿德里安·迈耶写的精彩书籍，她写了古人对古代化石的看法。她提出西西里岛上曾经有矮象，所以它们在古希腊时代之前很久就灭绝了。但它们的头骨可能被发现了。因为你有，你知道，你有象鼻，鼻腔，如果你看大象的头骨，
it does look a little bit like a kind of single eye. I mean, there's no proof for it, but it's a kind of, it's a wonderful idea. Is this not trying too hard to find a sort of banal, mundane explanation for what's clearly a fantastical story? I mean, to me, it would seem like this isn't inspired by skulls of like elephants. This is inspired by the fear of the unknown, the fear of the monstrous, all of that kind of stuff. I think that the story of these monsters lurking on strange islands, that these are, anxieties that are bred of the age in which the Odyssey is being written down. And it's an age when Greek colonists are starting to settle Sicily and the western reaches of the Mediterranean.
它看起来确实有点像一只单眼。我的意思是，没有证据证明这一点，但这是一种绝妙的想法。这难道不是在试图为显然是幻想的故事寻找一种平庸、世俗的解释吗？我的意思是，对我来说，这似乎不是受到大象头骨的启发。这是受到对未知的恐惧、对怪物的恐惧以及所有这些东西的启发。我认为这些怪物潜伏在奇怪岛屿上的故事，是《奥德赛》成书时代所产生的焦虑。那是一个希腊殖民者开始在西西里岛和地中海西部边缘定居的时代。
And I think that Polyphemus is a kind of nightmarish vision of a barbarian who does not live by the rules of life that the Greeks associate with civilization. So that's why Homer specifies that he drinks his wine neat. It's why. he specifies that there's no agriculture. These are people who, by the standards of the Greek colonists, are backward and savage and kind of frightening for that reason. So clearly, as you say, I mean, Polyphemus is a figure of fantasy, one of the most memorable figures in the whole history of fantasy.
我认为波吕斐摩斯是一种野蛮人的噩梦般的愿景，他不遵守希腊人与文明联系在一起的生活规则。这就是为什么荷马特别指出他喝纯酒。这就是为什么他特别指出那里没有农业。这些人按照希腊殖民者的标准，是落后和野蛮的，因此令人恐惧。所以很明显，正如你所说，波吕斐摩斯是一个幻想人物，是整个幻想史上最令人难忘的人物之一。
But he is clearly, I think, bringing to life the anxieties of adventurers who are sailing into strange seas and settling lands that are often very hostile. So there is a brilliant book on this by a scholar called Carol Doughty, The Raft of Odysseus. And to quote from that, embedded within a familiar mythic story pattern of a time and people long ago are details and themes that belong to the contemporary world of its audience. And that's kind of what you would expect. And it reminds me a bit of the way in which in the 1960s in start of, Trek. If you watch it now, it's Captain Kirk going around, you know, strange planets and all of that. But so many of those episodes are plainly about anxieties and complex that are manifest in 1960s
但我认为，他显然是在让那些航行到陌生海域并定居在往往非常敌对的土地上的冒险者的焦虑变得鲜活起来。所以有一本关于这个的精彩书籍，由学者卡罗尔·多蒂所著，《奥德修斯的木筏》。引用其中的话，嵌入在一个古老时代和人民的熟悉神话故事模式中，是属于其受众当代世界的细节和主题。这正是你所期望的。这让我想起20世纪60年代《星际迷航》的方式。如果你现在看它，那是柯克船长在奇怪的行星上航行，所有这些。但其中许多剧集显然是关于20世纪60年代美国显现的焦虑和情结。
America. And you would think that probably, you know, mutatus mutandes, the same is true of what's going on in the Odyssey, that this is fantastical, but it is also kind of drawing on all kinds of anxieties that reflect the character of the age in Greece. So let's take the next adventure they have. So this is the island of King Aeolus and he is what? He's the god of the winds. Yeah, he's the god of the winds. And on one level, as with the Cyclops, he's plainly a fantastical figure because his island is, it floats and it has ramparts made of unbreakable bronze. And yet at the same time, the Greeks were so confident where his island was anchored that to this day, we call the archipelago of islands, the Iolian islands. Oh yeah.
你会认为，可能，你知道，在改变了需要改变的地方后，同样的情况也适用于《奥德赛》中发生的事情，即这是幻想，但它也借鉴了反映希腊时代特征的各种焦虑。那么让我们看看他们的下一次冒险。所以这是风神埃俄罗斯的岛屿，他是谁？他是风神。是的，他是风神。从一个层面来看，和独眼巨人一样，他显然是一个幻想人物，因为他的岛屿是漂浮的，有由坚不可摧的青铜制成的城墙。然而与此同时，希腊人对他的岛屿锚定在哪里如此自信，以至于直到今天，我们仍称这些岛屿群为伊奥利亚群岛。哦，是的。
Of course. It was clearly a very, very strong tradition as to where IOLUS had actually been. I've been to the Aeolian lines. They're very nice. Lovely. There you go. You're following in the footsteps of Odysseus. And Iolus, unlike Polyphemus, is a very civilised man.
当然。关于埃俄罗斯实际上在哪里，显然有一个非常、非常强烈的传统。我去过伊奥利亚群岛。它们非常漂亮。可爱。你看。你正在追随奥德修斯的脚步。而埃俄罗斯，与波吕斐摩斯不同，是一个非常文明的人。
And he's obedient to the Greek laws of what they call Xenia, which is hospitality towards foreigners. If you meet a foreigner, the kind of mutual exchange of gifts, the contrast with Polyphemus is very obvious and deliberate, I think. And Iola hosts Odysseus and his men for an entire month in his kind of magnificent palace with its great bronze walls and all of that. And then he places all the contrary winds, the winds that would prevent Odysseus from getting back to Ithaca in a massive great bag. And he gives this bag to Odysseus to keep in his hold. So you can imagine the bag kind of bulging and moving with all these winds trying to get out. So that the west wind will blow him back home. And Iola says, you'll be absolutely fine with this.
他遵守希腊人所谓的“Xenia”法律，即对外国人的好客。如果你遇到一个外国人，那种礼物的相互交换，与波吕斐摩斯的对比是非常明显和故意的，我认为。埃俄罗斯在那种宏伟的宫殿里接待了奥德修斯和他的手下整整一个月，宫殿有巨大的青铜墙等等。然后他把所有相反的风，那些会阻止奥德修斯回到伊萨卡的风，放在一个巨大的袋子里。他把这个袋子给奥德修斯放在他的船舱里。所以你可以想象袋子因为所有这些试图出来的风而鼓起和移动。这样西风就会把他吹回家。埃俄罗斯说，你带着这个会绝对没问题的。
It's just, you know, just bear in mind the one thing, whatever you do, do not open that bag. And just to reiterate, whatever you do, do not open that bag. And so, Odysseus, to make absolutely sure that the winds do not escape from the bag, for nine days and nights, he doesn't sleep. He sits there kind of keeping his eye on the bag. And finally, they are so close to Ithaca that Odysseus can see smoke rising from hearth fires on the island. he is so nearly there. He's been awake all this time
只是，你知道，记住一件事，无论你做什么，都不要打开那个袋子。再重申一遍，无论你做什么，都不要打开那个袋子。所以，奥德修斯为了确保风不会从袋子里逃出来，九天九夜，他没有睡觉。他坐在那里，盯着袋子。最后，他们离伊萨卡如此之近，以至于奥德修斯可以看到岛上炉火升起的烟雾。他离家如此之近。他一直醒着
and so fatally he dozes off very briefly. And his men, seeing him at sleep, they're aware that he's been watching this bag and so they start muttering among themselves and say, well, what's in the bag? I mean, why is he so anxious about it? Clearly it must be full of treasure
所以致命的是，他非常短暂地打了个盹。他的手下看到他睡着了，他们意识到他一直在看管这个袋子，所以他们开始私下嘀咕，说，袋子里是什么？我的意思是，他为什么这么焦虑？显然它一定装满了宝藏，
and he's keeping it for himself and he's not sharing it with us and it's not fair. So let's open up the bag and share the treasure out among ourselves before we arrive in Ithaca and they pull on the rope they undo the bag the winds come screaming and howling
他把它留给自己，不和我们分享，这不公平。所以让我们在到达伊萨卡之前打开袋子，把宝藏分给我们自己。他们拉动绳子，解开袋子，风尖叫着、咆哮着
out of the bag massive great storms Odysseus is blown all the way back to the island of IOLUS and when he goes up to IOLUS and says what has happened Have you any more winds? Well basically he says will you put them in the bag again
从袋子里冲出来，巨大的风暴，奥德修斯被吹回了埃俄罗斯的岛屿。当他去找埃俄罗斯说发生了什么事时，你还有更多的风吗？好吧，基本上他说，你会再把它们放进袋子里吗？
and Iola says no get out for it's clear that you've come here as one hated by the gods. And again, you could see how, if you're venturing, say, into the Western Mediterranean from Greece, a knowledge of the winds is going to be really important. You know, getting information from local sources would be a requirement for anyone who wants to make a successful voyage. So again, I think you can see how that might feed into a story like this. Yeah, completely. So things that have gone wrong for them. And for the next six days,
埃俄罗斯说，不，滚出去，因为很明显你来到这里是被神所憎恨的人。同样，你可以看到，如果你从希腊冒险进入地中海西部，对风的了解将非常重要。你知道，从当地来源获取信息将是任何想要成功航行的人的要求。所以同样，我认为你可以看到这如何可能融入像这样的故事中。是的，完全是。所以对他们来说出错的事情。在接下来的六天里，
they have to row, don't they? Six days and nights. And they arrive in this fantastic harbour. It's a perfect harbour. Yeah. High cliffs, headlands, encircling it. And 11 of the ships go in and Odysseus's ship stays outside. And this is Odysseus being smart again because Tom, what happens next?
他们不得不划船，不是吗？六天六夜。他们到达了这个奇妙的港口。这是一个完美的港口。是的。高耸的悬崖，岬角，环绕着它。11艘船进去了，奥德修斯的船留在外面。这是奥德修斯再次表现聪明，因为汤姆，接下来发生了什么？
Yeah, because he can see it's a perfect harbour, but that also makes it a perfect trap. And Odysseus is very sensible not to have just gone ploughing in because this turns out. because this turns out to be the land of a people called the Lestrogonians, who, again, are giant cannibals, and there are thousands of them. And they all mass on the cliffs that surround this perfect harbour. And again, to Quaythoma, from the cliffs, they kept hurling down boulders, any one of which a man would be hard-pressed to lift. And the ships, you know, they're trapped inside this harbour,
是的，因为他能看出这是一个完美的港口，但这也使它成为一个完美的陷阱。奥德修斯非常明智，没有直接冲进去，因为这结果证明是莱斯特律戈涅斯人的土地，他们同样是巨大的食人族，有成千上万个。他们都聚集在环绕这个完美港口的悬崖上。再次引用荷马的话，从悬崖上，他们不断投下巨石，任何一块石头一个人都很难举起。而船只，你知道，它们被困在这个港口里，
and they are rapidly reduced to matchwood. And the Lestrugonians then wade out into the sea, and they spear Odysseus' men like their fish, like their tuna, and only Odysseus and his now solitary ship escaped the slaughter. So people will remember that curse that Polyphemus had laid on Odysseus that he would return without his men. Well, 11 of those ships have gone. And again, is there a real life equivalent to this?
它们很快变成了火柴棍。莱斯特律戈涅斯人随后涉水进入大海，像叉鱼一样叉奥德修斯的手下，像叉金枪鱼一样，只有奥德修斯和他现在孤独的船逃过了屠杀。所以人们会记得波吕斐摩斯对奥德修斯下的诅咒，他将失去手下独自归来。好吧，那11艘船已经没了。同样，这有现实生活中的对应物吗？
So you were talking about the Aeolian Islands and the lotus eaters, you know, the explanation of the lotus eaters. what do historians think about the Lestrogonians? The Greeks identified it again with Sicily, and this is a period where they're starting to settle Sicily. And again, I think the story speaks of anxieties about murderous natives. And I think there's the specific twist here, which is with your ships, you see a perfect spot for a colony.
所以你刚才在谈论伊奥利亚群岛和食莲人，你知道，对食莲人的解释。历史学家对莱斯特律戈涅斯人有什么看法？希腊人再次将其与西西里岛联系起来，这是一个他们开始在西西里岛定居的时期。同样，我认为这个故事讲述了对凶残土著的焦虑。我认为这里有一个具体的转折，就是关于你的船，你看到了一个殖民的完美地点。
I mean, it might be a perfect spot, but that might make it all the more dangerous, because perfect spots would presumably already be settled and there would be people who would not welcome your arrival. So again, I think you can see how these stories of colonisation and settlement that are coterminous with Homer's composition of Theodosy, that this is probably what's going on, probably feeding into stories like that. Okay, so we've had a few stories that seem quite obviously to reflect anxieties about the Greek
我的意思是，它可能是一个完美的地点，但这可能使它更加危险，因为完美的地点大概已经被定居了，会有不欢迎你到来的人。所以同样，我认为你可以看到这些与荷马创作《奥德赛》同时代的殖民和定居故事，这可能就是正在发生的事情，可能融入了这样的故事中。好的，所以我们已经听了几个似乎非常明显地反映了对希腊殖民时代焦虑的故事。但下一次冒险要奇怪得多，不是吗？这更像是进入某种幻想梦境之类的东西。是的。再次追求科幻平行，这是，你知道，你正在穿过虫洞或经历奇点。你正在进入一个不同的维度，那里正常规则被暂停了。然而，奥德修斯并不立即明显地知道发生了什么。所以他们从莱斯特律戈涅斯人那里逃脱了。
age of colonisation. But the next adventure is much stranger, isn't it? And this is much more like a sort of going into some fantasy dream scape or something. Yeah. Again, to kind of pursue the science fiction parallel, this is, you know, you're going through a wormhole or experiencing a singularity. You're going into a different dimension where the rules of what are normal are suspended. However, it's not immediately obvious to Odysseus that this is what has happened. So they've made their escape from the Lestrogonians.
他们继续航行，风吹着他们，他们到达了另一个岛屿，他们在那里停泊，起初一切看起来完全正常。奥德修斯去执行侦察任务，他遇到了一头雄鹿，他杀了它，把它带回来，他们都又来了一次烧烤。第二天，奥德修斯想深入岛屿的腹地，所以他把手下分成两组，一组由他带领，一组由一个特别勇敢的船员尤里洛科斯带领。抽签决定他们中的哪一组去探索，哪一组留下来看守船只。抽签结果是尤里洛科斯去内陆，试图侦察岛上可能有什么人或东西。所以尤里洛科斯和他的侦察队前往内陆。
they keep sailing as the wind blows them and they arrive at another island they moor off it and at first everything seems completely normal odysseus goes on a scouting mission he runs into a stag he kills it he brings it back they all have another barbecue the next day adysius wants to go deeper into the hinterland of the island so he divides his men into two groups one led by him one led by a particularly brave crew member called Eurilicus and lots of cast to see which one of them, which of these two groups will go and explore and which will stay and look after the ship. And the lot falls on Eurilicus to go inland and to try and scout out who or what might be on this island. So Eurlicus and his scouting party head inland.
不久，他们来到了一座美丽的宫殿，有广阔的草坪和花园。花园里有狼和狮子。所以可以理解，尤里洛科斯的部下拔出了剑，他们对这些掠食者感到紧张。但狮子和狼看起来异常温顺。它们像家犬一样向尤里洛科斯和他的部下摇尾乞怜。当他们对此感到疑惑并思考这里到底发生了什么时，从宫殿里面他们听到了一个女人的美丽声音，她在唱歌。
And in due course they come to a beautiful palace with spreading lawns and gardens. And there are wolves and lions in this garden. And so understandably Eurilicus' men draw their swords. they're nervous of these predators. But the lions and wolves seem weirdly tame. And they fawn on eurylicus and his men like their domestic dogs. And while they're wondering about this and thinking what on earth is going on here, from inside the palace they hear the beautiful voice of a woman and she's singing.
她显然在织布机上工作。他们呼唤她，这个女人来到他们面前。她打开了这些巨大的闪亮大门，邀请他们进去。她非常华丽，穿着漂亮，我的意思是，显然是一位女王。所以尤里洛科斯的所有部下，除了尤里洛科斯本人，都走了进去。尤里洛科斯，显然是被奥德修斯选中的，因为他具有奥德修斯所认同的怀疑和智慧品质，他留在了外面。他不信任这个女人。
And she's clearly working on a loom. And they call out to her and this woman comes to them. and she opens these great gleaming doors and she invites them in. And she is fabulously gorgeous, beautifully dressed, I mean, clearly a queen. And so all Eurylicus is men, except for Eurylicus himself, they walk inside. Eurylicus, who has clearly been chosen by Odysseus because he has a quality of suspicion and intelligence that Odysseus identifies with, he stays outside. He doesn't trust this woman.
或者什么，她身上有一点邪恶。他没猜错，因为这个女人让尤里洛科斯的部下坐在沙发上，然后她给他们带来食物，奶酪、大麦和黄褐色的蜂蜜，还有普拉姆尼安葡萄酒。我们被告知，这些食物和饮料中混合了邪恶的药物。尤里洛科斯的部下吃喝得饱饱的。然后一旦他们吃饱了，女人走在用餐区周围，她用魔杖敲了敲他们，他们立即开始变成猪。他们的头、他们的咕噜声、他们的鬃毛、他们的身体，尽管他们的思想和以前一样
or something, a little bit sinister about her. And he's not wrong, because the woman seats Eurylicus's men down on couches, and then she brings them food, cheese and barley and tawny honey together with pramnean wine. And this food and this drink, we're told, are mixed with sinister drugs. And Eurlicus's men eat and drink their fill. And then once they have gorged themselves, the woman walks a woman. around the dining area and she taps them with a wand and immediately they start turning into pigs. Their heads, their grunts, their bristles, their bodies, although their minds were as
健全。所以他们是困在猪身体里的人类。尤里洛科斯目睹了这一切，他设法逃脱并跑回奥德修斯那里，向奥德修斯报告，从这一点开始，故事变得更加奇怪。所以奥德修斯决心从咒语中拯救他的部下。你知道，除了其他事情，他需要他们。没有他们他将无法划船。所以他出发去面对这个显然是女巫的女人。在路上，他在流浪过程中第一次遇到了一个真正的奥林匹斯神，奥林匹斯山上的前12位神之一。这就是赫尔墨斯，众神的信使。所以显然是被某人派来的，我们推测是雅典娜来帮助他。赫尔墨斯给了他一个距离。
sound as they'd always been. So they are humans trapped in the bodies of a pig. And Eurylocus has watched all of this and he manages to get away and he runs back to Odysseus, reports it to Odysseus and from this point on the story becomes even stranger. So Odysseus is determined to redeeming his men from the spell. You know, aside from anything else, he needs them. He won't be able to kind of row the ship without them. So he sets off to confront this woman who is patently a sorceress. And on his way, he meets for the first time in the course of his wanderings, a bona fide Olympian, one of the top 12 gods on Mount Olympus. And this is Hermes, the messenger of the gods. So has clearly been sent by someone, we presume Athena to help him out. And Hermes gives a distance.
他自己的一种令人敬畏的药物。这是一种黑根白花的草药，叫做莫利。有了莫利，虽然不清楚莫利到底可能基于什么。但总之，它非常强大。那是伟大的魔法。奥德修斯证明了对女巫的咒语免疫。尽管我们发现。这个女巫本身就是一位女神。
An awesome drug of his own. And this is a black-rooted herb with a white flower called the moly. And armed with the moly, and it's unclear exactly what the moly might be based on. But anyway, it's very powerful. That's great magic. Odysseus proves immune to the sorceress's spells. And this is despite the fact that we discover. This sorceress is herself a goddess.
她是太阳的女儿。她的名字是拥有美丽辫子的喀耳刻。在剑尖下，奥德修斯强迫喀耳刻屈服，喀耳刻屈服了，然后邀请奥德修斯上床。奥德修斯说，没门，除非你发誓对我发一个大誓，女神，不再策划任何旨在伤害我的邪恶。喀耳刻发了誓，然后奥德修斯和她上了床。她随后将他的部下恢复为人形，比以前更年轻，现在更英俊，看起来也更高大。所以这一切都解决得很好。
She is a daughter of the son. And her name is Circe of the beautiful braids. And at sword point, Odysseus forces Circe to submit, and Sircy submits and then invites Odysseus to bed. And Odysseus says, no way, unless you could bear to swear a great oath to me, goddess, not to plot any more evil that is meant to do me harm. And Circe swears the oath, and then Odysseus goes to bed with her. She then restores his men to human form, younger than before, far more handsome now, and much more. taller to look upon. So that's all worked out well.
但随后转折来了，你可能期望奥德修斯匆忙离开，你知道，但他没有。他待了一年。他和他的船员在喀耳刻那里待了一年，不是吗？实际上，奥德修斯似乎非常享受这一点，以至于他的部下跑来对他说，你忘记回家了吗？我们本该回家的。你那高屋顶的房子和你祖先的土地还在等着你，伊萨卡，来吧，让我们继续前进离开。这里发生了什么，
But then the twist, you might expect Odysseus to rush off, you know, but he doesn't. He stays for a year. He and his crew stay with Circe for a year, don't they? And actually, Odysseus seems to be enjoying this so much that it's his men who come to him and say, have you forgotten about going home? We were meant to be going home. Your house with its high-built roof and the land of your fathers. is still is waiting for you, Ithaca, and come on, let's crack on and leave. And what is going on here,
你认为？所以这是对性欲的寓言吗？是女性的诡计吗？这到底是怎么回事？它显然使奥德修斯作为一个被某种绝对专注于回到伊萨卡和他心爱的妻子佩涅洛佩的动力所驱动的人的概念变得复杂化。而且，你知道，人们显然会对此感到好奇。奥德修斯本应忠于他的妻子。他与喀耳刻的性关系对荷马来说完全不是问题。人们期望一个男人，无论他多么忠于他的妻子，显然都会在外面乱搞。这是一个绝对的既定事实。但我认为这一集有一种怪异感。显然，它不是自然主义的，因为它是一个把人变成小猪的女人。
do you think? So is this an allegory for sexual desire? Is it female wiles? What's, what's all this about? It clearly complicates the notion of Odysseus as a man driven by a kind of, you know, an absolute focus on getting back to Ithaca and to his beloved wife, Penelope. And just, you know, people will obviously be wondering about this. Edisius is meant to be. be devoted to his wife. His sexual relationship with Searcy is a complete non-issue to Homer. It's expected that a man, no matter how much he may be devoted to his wife, will obviously sleep around him. It's an absolute given. I think there is a kind of eerieness to this episode, though. Obviously, it's not naturalistic because it's a woman who's turning to sleep
但我认为我们不应该把这里的时间流逝仅仅理解为，你知道，他玩得很开心，他没注意到发生了什么。然后不知不觉中，一年过去了。我认为喀耳刻身上有一种萨满的特质，那种她把奥德修斯和他的部下带入了一个神秘和魔法维度的感觉，时间以不同的速度移动。所以她提供给奥德修斯的东西，我认为，类似于一种启蒙。一年几乎在眨眼间就过去了。当奥德修斯走过去说，看，我真的想继续前进，喀耳刻并不反对这一点，但她说，在你这样做之前，
little pigs. But I don't think we should understand the passage of time here as simply being, you know, he's having a great time, he fails to notice what's going on. And then before you know it, a year's gone by. I think that there's a kind of quality. of the shaman about Searcy, the sense that she has conducted Odysseus and his men into a dimension of mystery and magic where time moves at a different pace. And so what she's offering Odysseus, I think, is kind of akin to an initiation. And the year passes pretty much in the blink of an eye. And when Odysseus goes through and says, look, I really want to carry on, Circe doesn't object to this, but she says, before you do this,
你必须走得更远，越过我的岛屿，到达哈迪斯和可怕的珀耳塞福涅的住所。哈迪斯和珀耳塞福涅是死者的国王和王后。他们统治冥界。喀耳刻正在把奥德修斯送到哈迪斯的土地上。因为在这里在死者的土地上，你有雾，你有云，它笼罩着海洋的最远边界。如果他到达死者的土地，他可以咨询一个能够告诉他回家最好方法的人。这就是伟大的先知特瑞西阿斯。我们已经在《其余皆历史》的一集中见过他，我们关于俄狄浦斯的那一集。他已经死了，现在在冥界。
this, you must go even further beyond my island to the dwelling place of Hades and dread Persephone. And Hades and Persephone are the king and queen of the dead. They rule the underworld. And Circe is sending Odysseus onto the land of Hades. Because here in the land of the dead, you've got mist, you've got cloud, it shrouds the farthest boundaries of ocean. If he gets to the land of the said, he can consult with someone who will be able to tell him the best way to get back home. And this is the great prophet, Terracias. And we have already met him in an episode of The Rest Is History, the episode that we did on Oedipus. And he's died and he's now in the underworld.
我认为这里有一种超级英雄系列的感觉，不是吗？一部电影的主角在另一部电影中以配角身份出现。是的，这是喀耳刻电影宇宙。实际上，你读过玛德琳·米勒关于喀耳刻的小说吗？是的。很棒，不是吗？它从她的角度为你提供了整个情节。
And I think there is something, it's a kind of something of the superhero franchise, isn't there here? That characters who are the star of one film kind of reappear. is a bit of a bit part in another. Yeah, this is the Circee's cinematic universe. Actually, have you read Madeline Miller's novel about Circe? Yes. Brilliant, isn't it? It gives you the whole episode from her perspective.
总之，奥德修斯和同伴，他们前往哈迪斯的土地，这是以前从未有人做过的事情。他们是第一艘航行到那里的船。我的意思是，谁知道你可以航行到那里？这对我很惊讶。这就是为什么你需要喀耳刻告诉你这样的事情。对。以前从来没有人想过要这样做。
Anyway, Odysseus and Coe, they go off to the land of Hades, and this is something that nobody has ever done before. They're the first ship ever to sail to. I mean, who knew that you could sail there? This was a surprise to me. This is why you need Circe to tell you such things. Right. No one had ever thought to do it before.
而且，喀耳刻已经告诉他当他降落在死者土地上时该做什么，如何让鬼魂和他说话，因为有一个复杂情况。一旦你成为鬼魂，你说话的能力会迅速消失，直到你喝了血。所以喀耳刻说，
And also, Circe has told him what to do when he lands on the land of the dead, how to get the ghosts to talk to him, because there is a complication. Once you are a ghost, your ability to speak fades very rapidly until you have drunk blood. And so Circe has said,
带上一群羊，挖一条沟，当你挖好沟后，割断羊的喉咙，用血填满沟，鬼魂会被它像吸血鬼一样吸引，你必须阻止死者，直到特瑞西阿斯喝了血。
take a load of sheep, dig a trench, then when you've dug the trench, slit the throats of the sheep, and fill the trench with blood, the ghosts will be drawn by it like vampires, and you have to keep the dead at bay until Terracius has drunk.
这就是它。特瑞西阿斯喝了血，然后他就能说话了。他给了奥德修斯各种绝妙的旅行建议。所以他说，这是你必须记住的关键事情。你可能会发现自己降落在一个叫特里纳基亚的岛屿上。这个岛屿是献给太阳神赫利俄斯·许珀里翁的。这就是你读到的开头提到的神，多米尼克。
And this is what it is. Does Theraceus drinks the blood, and then he's able to talk. And he gives Odysseus all kinds of brilliant travel tips. So he says, this is the crucial thing you have to bear in mind. You may find yourself landing on an island called Thrinacia. And this island is sacred to Helios, the sun god, Hyperion. This is the god mentioned in the opening that you read Dominic.
如果你发现自己在岛上，无论你做什么，都不要杀死并烧烤牛群。你有一种喜欢烧烤胜过一切的人的氛围。他绝对是，你知道，他已经看穿了他们。是的，澳大利亚人。不要烧烤。只是不要这样做，因为如果你做了，一切都会出错。特瑞西阿斯告诉奥德修斯会出错的细节。
If you find yourself on this island, no matter what you do, Do not kill and barbecue the cattle. You have the vibe of people who love nothing more than a barbecue. He's absolutely kind of, you know, he's put his finger on them. Yeah, Australians. Don't have a barbecue. Just don't do it because if you do, everything will go wrong. And Terasius tells Odysseus the details of what will go wrong.
你会在失去所有同伴后，乘坐一艘不属于你自己的船，迟迟归来，孤苦伶仃。当然，这呼应了波吕斐摩斯早些时候对奥德修斯下的诅咒。特瑞西阿斯继续说，如果你和你的部下杀了这些牛，当你回到家时，你会发现你的大厅里挤满了无赖，骚扰和追求你的妻子。所以，你知道，只是不要去那里。所以，特瑞西阿斯，你知道，他喝饱了，然后他给了这个建议，然后他以一种幽灵般的方式飘走了。然后所有其他的阴影开始以血为食。而且我认为，你知道，令人难以置信的邪恶场景。然后奥德修斯和他们中的一些人交谈。
You will get back home late and hapless after losing all your comrades on a ship that is not your own. And of course, that is echoing the curse that Polyphemus had laid on Odysseus earlier. And Terracius goes on and says that if you and your men kill this cattle, you will find your halls when you get back home filled with braggots, pestering and courting your wife. So just, you know, just don't go there. So, Terracius, you know, he's drunk his fill and then he gives this advice and then he kind of flits away in a kind of spectral manner. And then all the other shades start to feed on the blood. And I think, you know, incredibly sinister scene. And then Odysseus talks to some of them.
其中有他的母亲，她在奥德修斯在特洛伊时去世了。你知道，他没有意识到她已经死了。他三次试图拥抱她。三次她就像影子或梦一样在他怀里融化。他遇到了阿伽门农，人类之王，特洛伊阿凯亚人的指挥官。他被他的妻子克吕泰涅斯特拉谋杀了。所以他告诉奥德修斯那个故事。然后非常著名的是，奥德修斯遇到了《伊利亚特》的伟大英雄，所有阿凯亚战士中最伟大的，阿喀琉斯，那个在《伊利亚特》结尾杀死了特洛伊最伟大战士赫克托耳的人。
And among them is his mother who had died while he was away in Troy. You know, he hadn't realized that she was dead. And three times he tries to embrace her. And three times she just kind of melts in his arms, like a shadow or a dream. He meets Agamemnon, the king of men, the commander of the Achaeans at Troy. He's been murdered by his wife, Clytemnestra. And so he tells Odysseus the story of that. And then very famously, Odysseus meets the great hero of the Iliad, the greatest of all the Achaean warriors, Achilles, the man who at the end of the Iliad had killed Hector, the greatest of the Trojan warriors.
阿喀琉斯在很年轻时就被提供了选择：短暂但充满荣耀的生活，或者漫长但默默无闻的生活。阿喀琉斯告诉奥德修斯，我犯了一个可怕的错误。我选择了充满荣耀的短暂生活。但我宁愿作为另一个人的奴隶在地球上生活，某个只有微薄份额、勉强维持生计的人，也不愿在这里统治所有那些死去的灵魂。所以对我来说，这是整个《奥德赛》中最有趣的时刻，因为它破坏了英雄崇拜以及对荣耀和武力的强调
And Achilles had been offered the choice when he was very young of a life short but full of glory or a long life but living in obscurity. And Achilles tells Odysseus, I made a terrible mistake. I went for the short life full of glory. But I would far rather live off the earth as the surf of another man, some man with a pitiful portion who barely eeks out a living, than rule here as the Lord of all those who are dead and gone. So to me, that is the single most interesting moments of the entire Odyssey, because it undermines the cult of the hero and the sort of the emphasis on glory and martial vigour
以及用永远不会褪色的霓虹灯字母写下你的名字等等。基本上，荷马暗示有一种论点，这有点像玛德琳·米勒的书，喀耳刻，这就是特勒马科斯所说的。默默无闻更好。实际上，过一种安静的生活，没有人知道你的存在，比成为一个伟大的英雄，你知道，被荣耀所笼罩等等要好。这一切都会过去，毫无意义。是的，我认为这绝对是它所说的。但阿喀琉斯本质上所说的是，所有礼物中最伟大的是永生。你知道，你永远不想死。如果你曾经被提供永生的礼物，你会张开双臂拥抱它。我的意思是，这本质上就是他所说的。这是将影响奥德修斯在适当时候必须做出的决定的事情，但我们会谈到这一点。但你认为荷马真的意思是他的听众应该思考一下他们的荣耀崇拜等等，还是不？
and writing your name in neon letters that will never fade and all of that kind of thing. And basically, Homer is implying that there is an argument for saying, it's a bit like in the Madeline Miller book, Cursi, this is what Telemachus says. It's better to be obscure. It's actually better to have a nice, quiet life and no one knows you even exist than to be a great hero and, you know, to be wreathed in glory and stuff. That is all, that all passes and it's meaningless. Yes, I think that's absolutely what's saying. But also what Achilles is saying essentially is the greatest of all gifts is immortality. You know, you never want to die. if you ever get offered the gift of immortality, you want to embrace it with open arms. I mean, that is essentially what he's saying. And that is something that will impact on a decision that Odysseus has to make in due course, but we will come to that. But do you think Homer genuinely means it that his listeners should have a think about their cult of glory and all of that, or not?
我认为这是笼罩希腊人对竞争、英雄主义、勇气、荣耀的奉献的事情之一。事实是，除了最伟大的人之外，没有基督教或穆斯林天堂的对应物，死亡是一种阴暗、沉闷的存在，你是一种喋喋不休的影子，甚至必须喝血才能说话。我的意思是，你知道，那里什么都没有。所以它使生命的光芒更加辉煌。所以总之，正如你所说，我的意思是，这是诗中一个令人惊叹、令人惊叹的时刻。在古希腊文化的最广泛范围内。所以奥德修斯得到了他想要的东西。他
I think that it is one of the things that shadows the Greek devotion to competition, to heroism, to courage, to glory. is the fact that there is no equivalent of the Christian or Muslim heaven for all but the very greatest, that death is a shadowy, dull existence where you're a kind of a gibbering shadow, who has to drink blood even to speak. I mean, it's, you know, there's nothing there. And so it makes the blaze of life all the more kind of glorious. So anyway, as you say, I mean, it is an amazing, amazing moment in the poem. in the kind of broadest sweep of ancient Greek culture. So Odysseus has got what he came for. He's
我认为这正是掩盖了希腊人对竞争、英雄主义、勇气和荣耀的追求的因素之一。事实上，除了极少数最伟大的人之外，希腊人并没有基督教或伊斯兰教意义上的天堂。死亡是一种阴暗、沉闷的存在，你就像一个只会胡言乱语的影子，甚至必须喝血才能开口说话。我的意思是，那里什么都没有。因此，这使得生命的闪耀显得更加辉煌。总之，正如你所说，这确实是这首诗中一个令人惊叹的时刻，也是古希腊文化宏大叙事中的一个重要瞬间。所以，奥德修斯得到了他想要的东西。他已经
got this advice from Terracius. And so now he goes back to the Lady Circe who feasts them. And then after the meal, she says to Odysseus, OK, just go. As soon as dawn appears, set sail. And she then advises him on how he should negotiate the various dangers that will be awaiting him on the next stage of his voyage. And she says, you are going to be passing the island of the Sirens. And these are carnivorous creatures, heads of women, bodies of birds. They have irresistibly beautiful voices. So that's what the word siren means. And they sit on this island perched amid a great pile of bones. And Circe has a suggestion. She says, all your men should put wax in their ears so they can't hear it. And you, if you want to hear the song of the sirens, get your men to tie you to the mast.
从特里西亚斯那里得到了这个建议。现在他回到了款待他们的瑟西女神那里。饭后，她对奥德修斯说，好吧，走吧。黎明一出现，就起航。然后她建议他如何应对下一阶段航行中等待他的各种危险。她说，你们将经过塞壬岛。这些是食肉生物，长着女人的头，鸟的身体。它们有令人无法抗拒的美妙声音。这就是塞壬这个词的意思。它们栖息在这个岛上，坐在一堆巨大的骨头中间。瑟西有一个建议。她说，你们所有的人都应该在耳朵里塞上蜡，这样他们就听不见了。而你，如果你想听塞壬的歌声，就让你的手下把你绑在桅杆上。
and you will hear the song, you will order them to set you free, tell them on no account to set you free. And that way you can hear the song of the sirens and live to tell the tale. And then after that, you will pass two terrible monsters, Silla and Carybdis, and these guard the passage between two cliffs, and you have to sail between them. And in one of these cliffs, and this is a cliff which reaches all the way up to wide heaven and is ringed by a cloud of dark blue, there is a cave. and inside this cave lurks the monster Silla and Silla makes a noise like a little newborn puppy so it's so very very sweet However Silla has six necks
你会听到歌声，你会命令他们放了你，告诉他们无论如何都不要放了你。这样你就能听到塞壬的歌声，并活着讲述这个故事。在那之后，你会经过两个可怕的怪物，斯库拉和卡律布狄斯，它们守卫着两座悬崖之间的通道，你必须在它们之间航行。在其中一座悬崖上，这是一座直达广阔天空并被深蓝色云层环绕的悬崖，有一个洞穴。在这个洞穴里潜伏着怪物斯库拉，斯库拉发出的声音像一只刚出生的小狗，所以非常非常甜美。然而，斯库拉有六个脖子
enormously long and on top of each of the necks is a head harrowing sight each with three rows of teeth so not good news a bit like the alien in the scorny weaver film and from the other cliff sprouts a huge wild fig tree and beneath that in the wall depths of the waters lurks caribbidus. This is the second monster and every day
非常长，每个脖子上都有一个令人毛骨悚然的头，每个头都有三排牙齿，所以这不是什么好消息，有点像《异形》电影里的异形。从另一座悬崖上长出一棵巨大的野无花果树，在水下的深处潜伏着卡律布狄斯。这是第二个怪物，每天
Caribdis sucks the water down and then thrice each day she vomits it up, thrice she gulps it back down and this creates a monstrous whirlpool and any ship that gets caught in the whirlpool is doomed. It will be dragged round and round down and down into the jaws of Carreptus and everyone on that ship will be eaten. And so Circe's advice is steer clear of the whirlpool, stick close to Silla's Rock. For as Sertie says, it is better by far to mourn six of the men from your ship than to mourn all of them together. And as for the cattle of the sun, which Theracius had been majoring on, Circe says,
卡律布狄斯把水吸下去，然后每天三次把它吐出来，三次把它吞回去，这制造了一个巨大的漩涡，任何被卷入漩涡的船只都注定要灭亡。它会被拖得团团转，一直拖进卡律布狄斯的嘴里，船上的每个人都会被吃掉。所以瑟西的建议是避开漩涡，紧贴斯库拉的岩石。正如瑟西所说，哀悼船上的六个人远比哀悼所有人要好。至于特里西亚斯重点提到的太阳神的牛，瑟西说，
look, just don't land there. It's too dangerous. She's obviously sussed out the enthusiasm of Odysseus's men for barbecues and says, just, you know, they'll let them have the temptation. So Odysseus has got this advice from Searcy. He follows it to the letter. he does indeed become the only man to have heard the siren sing and live to tell the tale. He does lose six men to the six snaking necks of Silla that kind of descend from her cave and grabs them and kind of pulls them up into her cave and devas them.
听着，别在那里登陆。太危险了。她显然已经看穿了奥德修斯手下对烧烤的热情，并说，你知道，他们会让他们受到诱惑。所以奥德修斯从瑟西那里得到了这个建议。他严格执行了。他确实成为了唯一一个听过塞壬歌唱并活着讲述这个故事的人。他确实失去了六个人，被斯库拉的六个蛇形脖子抓走，这些脖子从她的洞穴里伸出来，把他们抓走并拉进洞穴吞食了。
But they manage to avoid the whirlpool of Charybdis and that's the main thing. And they sail on and they see the island of the sun. And Odysseus says, okay, we're not stopping here. No way. Because this is the bit, remember, Tyresius, you better to avoid it. Do not touch them. Of course we all, as soon as Darius said that, surely. we all knew what was going to happen.
但他们设法避开了卡律布狄斯的漩涡，这是最重要的事情。他们继续航行，看到了太阳神的岛屿。奥德修斯说，好吧，我们不在这里停留。绝对不行。因为这就是重点，记得吗，特里西亚斯，你最好避开它。不要碰它们。当然，当特里西亚斯这么说的时候，我们都知道会发生什么。
Yeah. Odysseus' men, when he says, look, we're not stopping here. They all complain. They say, look, oh, God, we're shattered. You know, we really need a break. It looks really nice. Please, come on. So very reluctantly, Odysseus says, okay, but, guys, whatever you do, don't touch the cattle.
是的。当奥德修斯说，听着，我们不在这里停留时，他的手下都抱怨了。他们说，看，天哪，我们累坏了。你知道，我们真的需要休息一下。这里看起来真的很不错。拜托，来吧。所以奥德修斯非常不情愿地说，好吧，但是，伙计们，无论你们做什么，都不要碰那些牛。
You know, just don't go there. We will stop there for a single afternoon, and then we will continue on our way. So they land. And then, unfortunately, the moment they land, there is a massive, great storm and it blows for a month and it is clearly of divine origin. It is preventing them from leaving the island. And so they're stuck there and they're really, really hungry. Their supplies are running out and Odysseus can see his men starting to eye up the cattle and thinking how nice, you know, chunks of this cattle would be if it were on a spit, you know, in a lovely kebab. And so in
你知道，别去碰它们。我们会在那里停留一个下午，然后继续我们的旅程。于是他们登陆了。不幸的是，他们刚一登陆，就刮起了一场巨大的风暴，持续了一个月，这显然是神的力量。它阻止了他们离开岛屿。所以他们被困在那里，真的非常非常饿。他们的补给快用完了，奥德修斯可以看到他的手下开始盯着那些牛，想着如果把这些牛放在烤肉叉上，做成美味的烤肉串该有多好。所以，在
desperation, he thinks, well, listen, clearly there is a god here who's angry. I need to go up onto the top of the mountain at the center of this island and raise a prayer there. So that's what he does. And he leaves his men behind and he heads off to the summit of the mountain on the top, in the middle of the island to raise prayers to the gods. And presumably before he goes, he does remind them, guys, don't eat the cattle. Don't eat the cattle. Did I mention, don't eat the cattle.
绝望中，他想，好吧，听着，显然这里有一位神在生气。我需要去岛中心的山顶上祈祷。所以他就是这么做的。他把手下留在后面，前往岛中间的山顶，向神祈祷。大概在他走之前，他确实提醒过他们，伙计们，不要吃牛。不要吃牛。我提过不要吃牛吗？
He reaches the mountain top. As before, with the winds of Iolus in the bag. So now, faithfully, he falls asleep. So there's something of the Lafayette about Odysseus falling asleep at crucial moments. And as he sleeps, his men obviously do what they've been told not to do. They kill and roast the sacred cattle. And the smell of kebabs drifts into the nostrils of Odysseus. He wakes up.
他到达了山顶。就像之前带着埃俄罗斯的风袋一样。所以现在，他忠实地睡着了。所以奥德修斯在关键时刻睡着，这有点像拉斐特。当他睡觉时，他的手下显然做了他们被告知不要做的事情。他们杀死并烤了神圣的牛。烤肉串的味道飘进了奥德修斯的鼻孔。他醒了。
He looks down. He sees the smokes rise. He goes, ah, no. And he runs down. And for six days, his men make a feast. The wind, you know, they can't leave because of the winds. but it is very obvious that nothing good is going to come of this barbecue because the skins of the slain cattle keep moving around
他往下看。他看到烟雾升起。他说，啊，不。他跑了下去。六天来，他的手下一直在举行宴会。风，你知道，他们因为风而无法离开。但很明显，这次烧烤不会有什么好结果，因为被杀死的牛的皮一直在移动
and the meat on the kebab sticks keeps lowing. That's like a vegans fantasy, isn't it? Yeah. And it's not surprising because it is, I think, hard to overemphasize the scale of the insult that has been done to the sun god because these are clearly solar cattle. And notions of solar cattle seem to have been very widespread in the myths of the ancient Indo-Europeans.
烤肉串上的肉一直在哞哞叫。那就像素食者的幻想，不是吗？是的。这并不奇怪，因为我认为很难过分强调对太阳神造成的侮辱程度，因为这些显然是太阳牛。太阳牛的概念在古代印欧人的神话中似乎非常普遍。
So the Greeks are Indo-Europeans. You get it in Hindi mythology and Irish mythology, from India to Ireland, in other words. And their theft in all these stories, no matter where they're told, it always represents the kind of massive insult to the cosmic order. And so it is in the Odyssey. Elios, the sun god complains to Zeus.
所以希腊人是印欧人。你在印度神话和爱尔兰神话中也能看到，换句话说，从印度到爱尔兰。在所有这些故事中，无论在哪里讲述，它们的被盗总是代表着对宇宙秩序的巨大侮辱。在《奥德赛》中也是如此。太阳神赫利俄斯向宙斯抱怨。
Zeus stills the storms. So there's a very sinister calm. And this allows Odysseus and his men to set sail. And then all at once, once the ship is out at sea, Zeus thundered and hurled his lightning at the ship. And the mast of the ship snaps. And as it falls, it brains the helmsman and knocks him into the sea. So they now have no one to steer them.
宙斯平息了风暴。所以有一种非常险恶的平静。这让奥德修斯和他的手下得以起航。然后突然之间，一旦船到了海上，宙斯就打雷并向船投掷闪电。船的桅杆断了。当它倒下时，它击中了舵手并把他撞进了海里。所以他们现在没有人来掌舵了。
The ship spins round and round. The decking blazes with smoke like. sulfur and all of Odysseus's men are tossed into the kind of the great boiling royal of the sea, looking just like cormorants, they bobbed about on the waves all around the black hulled ship. The god snatched their homecoming from them. But only one man survives the shipwreck, and this is Odysseus himself. Somehow he manages to fashion a raft out of all the wreckage, all the flotsam and jetsam. But even now, even though he's got his raft, he's still not safe, because the wind
船转来转去。甲板上冒着硫磺般的烟雾，奥德修斯的所有手下都被抛进了大海那沸腾的漩涡中，看起来就像鸬鹚一样，在黑色的船身周围的波浪中上下浮动。神夺走了他们回家的路。但只有一个人在海难中幸存下来，那就是奥德修斯本人。不知何故，他设法用所有的残骸、所有的漂浮物做了一个木筏。但即使现在，尽管他有了木筏，他仍然不安全，因为风
changes and blows him back the way he had come towards Silla and Carybdis. And of course, he can't steer. So the whirlpool is swirling downwards. Carybdis is sucking the water down deep into her jaws. And Odysseus's raft gets caught up in the kind of the spinning and the whirling of the waters. As it's going down, Odysseus leaps up from the raft and he clings onto that giant fig tree, remember, which Homer had told us was leaning over the whirlpool, and he manages to hold onto it until the raft is spat back up by Carybdis, and he drops down from the branch that he's been holding onto, down beside the timbers, and sitting on top of them, as he later describes it, I used my hands to paddle away, and for nine days and nine nights, he drifts, and he is the only man
改变了方向，把他吹回了他来的方向，朝向斯库拉和卡律布狄斯。当然，他无法掌舵。所以漩涡在向下旋转。卡律布狄斯正在把水吸进她的嘴里。奥德修斯的木筏被卷入了水的旋转和漩涡中。当它下沉时，奥德修斯从木筏上跳起来，紧紧抓住那棵巨大的无花果树，记得吗，荷马告诉我们它悬在漩涡上方，他设法抓住它，直到木筏被卡律布狄斯吐出来，他从他一直抓住的树枝上跳下来，落在木材旁边，坐在它们上面，正如他后来描述的那样，我用手划走，九天九夜，他漂流着，他是唯一一个
left alive out of what had originally been a fleet of 12 ships. And the loss of those men in Homer's poem is very deeply felt because the Odyssey throughout the account of its hero's voyages and obviously the focus is very much on the hero. Nevertheless, it is unusual
在最初的12艘船的舰队中幸存下来的人。在荷马的诗中，这些人的损失被深深地感受到了，因为《奥德赛》在整个英雄航行的叙述中，显然重点非常集中在英雄身上。尽管如此，它还是不寻常的
for the emphasis that it places on the minor characters. You kind of come to know them. We haven't really been talking about them much because we haven't had the time. But when you're reading the poem, You feel for them. You mark their fates, even if they are idiots with their enthusiasm for barbecues.
因为它对次要角色的强调。你开始了解他们。我们并没有真正谈论他们太多，因为我们没有时间。但当你读这首诗时，你会为他们感到难过。你记住了他们的命运，即使他们是那些对烧烤充满热情的白痴。
I mean, they've only got themselves to blame, to be honest. And again, Skilling Carybdis, all of this stuff, you can see how this reflects the anxieties of an age and exploration and sea travel, the whirlpool, the cliffs, all of that. Yeah, so Cilinacrubdis was identified with the straits of Messina between Sicily and Italy, where you have whirlpools and riptides. and it was generally dreaded by ancient sailors. And Thranachia, the island of the cattle means three headlands. Sicily has three headlands. So again, it was identified with Sicily. And Sicily was the kind of main focus for Greek colonisation in this period.
我的意思是，老实说，他们只能怪自己。再说一次，斯库拉和卡律布狄斯，所有这些东西，你可以看出这反映了那个时代对探索和海上旅行的焦虑，漩涡，悬崖，所有这些。是的，所以斯库拉和卡律布狄斯被认为是西西里岛和意大利之间的墨西拿海峡，那里有漩涡和激流。它通常被古代水手所畏惧。而特里纳基亚，牛的岛屿，意味着三个岬角。西西里岛有三个岬角。所以它再次被认为是西西里岛。而西西里岛是这一时期希腊殖民的主要焦点。
So it's perhaps not surprising that it generated all these kind of, all these myths. But now, with the loss of his men and his ship, Odysseus, I think, is drifting back from the kind of the shipping lanes that Greek sailors might recognize back into a dimension beyond the mortal back through the kind of the Homeric equivalent of a wormhole. And it's telling, I think, that Homer does not describe in detail what happens next. All he really reports is that after nine days of drifting on the open seas, and this is Odysseus narrating at this point, on the 9th of the 10th, I was brought by the gods to the island of a Gigiya, home of Calypso, she of the beautiful braids, dread goddess who speaks like a mortal.
所以它产生了所有这些神话也就不足为奇了。但现在，随着他的手下和船只的损失，我认为奥德修斯正在从希腊水手可能认识的航道漂流回一个超越凡人的维度，穿过荷马式的虫洞。我认为荷马没有详细描述接下来发生的事情是很有意义的。他真正报告的只是，在海上漂流了九天之后，这是奥德修斯此时的叙述，在第十天的第九天，我被神带到了奥吉吉亚岛，那是卡吕普索的家，她有着美丽的辫子，说话像凡人的可怕女神。
She welcomed and cared for me. So it's slightly Circe-like, but the difference here is that whereas he stayed with Circei voluntarily, Calypso will not let him leave. That's right, isn't it? He's staying here almost against his will, day after day, month after month, year after year. he is, you know, weeping, he's thinking about Penelope, he's thinking about his son to Lemicus, about Ithaca, his home, and the greatest punishment of all every night he has to go to bed with Calypso. What a terrible ordeal this must have been. Yes, to quote Homer, compelled by the goddess
她欢迎并照顾我。所以这有点像瑟西，但这里的区别在于，虽然他是自愿和瑟西待在一起的，但卡吕普索不会让他离开。没错，是这样吧？他几乎违背自己的意愿留在这里，日复一日，月复一月，年复一年。他，你知道，在哭泣，他在想佩涅洛佩，他在想他的儿子特勒马科斯，关于伊萨卡，他的家，以及最大的惩罚，每天晚上他都必须和卡吕普索上床。这一定是一次多么可怕的折磨。是的，引用荷马的话，被女神强迫
to do so, he unwilling, she all too willing. So basically, Dominic, he's become a beautiful goddess's sex slave to a terrible fate. Oh no, what a terrible fate that is. So, Wow. Will he ever escape Tom? And if so, how will he do it? And what will happen when he gets back to Ithaca? If only there was some way I could find out the answers to all these questions, because I know you have amazing stories yet to tell us. I do. And brilliantly, Dominic, there is a way you can find out. You can listen to the second episode of this literally epic. I mean, literally epic. Yeah. And if you would like to get early access and you're not already a member of the rest of History Club, then you can join our own. rapid band of barbecuing mariners at the rest is history.com. And the amazing news, Tom, on top of that is that we're actually running a summer
这样做，他是不情愿的，她是太情愿了。所以基本上，多米尼克，他已经成为了一个美丽女神的性奴隶，面临着可怕的命运。哦不，那真是个可怕的命运。所以，哇。他能逃脱吗，汤姆？如果能，他会怎么做？当他回到伊萨卡时会发生什么？如果有什么方法能让我找到所有这些问题的答案就好了，因为我知道你还有精彩的故事要告诉我们。我有。而且太棒了，多米尼克，确实有一种方法可以找到答案。你可以听这个史诗系列的第二集。我的意思是，真的是史诗。是的。如果你想获得提前访问权限，而且你还不是历史俱乐部其余部分的成员，那么你可以加入我们。在restishistory.com加入我们快速的烧烤水手行列。而且令人惊奇的消息，汤姆，最重要的是，我们实际上正在进行夏季
sale at the moment. So for a limited time only, you can get 20% off annual membership if you use the code summer 26. And that code is valid until the 31st of August. So do, it's what Odysseus would have wanted. Certainly what Homer, a great fan of storytelling, would have wanted, go online, use this code, get your discounted membership, and listen to that next episode right away. And of course, also Dominic, they'll be able to listen to the bonus episode with Daniel Mendelsohn. The great translator of the Odyssey. Great translator of the Odyssey. So it's just insane value all round, isn't it? I think too many benefits actually now. This is too good. We're giving stuff away and it's madness. Right. On that bombshell, we'll see you next time to find out
促销。所以，在有限的时间内，如果你使用代码summer 26，你可以获得年度会员20%的折扣。该代码有效期至8月31日。所以，这是奥德修斯想要的。当然也是荷马，一个伟大的讲故事爱好者想要的，上网，使用这个代码，获得你的折扣会员资格，并立即收听下一集。当然，多米尼克，他们也将能够收听丹尼尔·门德尔松的奖励剧集。伟大的《奥德赛》翻译家。伟大的《奥德赛》翻译家。所以这简直是全方位的疯狂价值，不是吗？我认为现在福利太多了。这太好了。我们正在赠送东西，这太疯狂了。好吧。在那颗重磅炸弹上，我们下次见，看看
what happens to our hero Odysseus. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Hello there, it's Al Murray here and James Holland there, hosts of the Second World War Pod, we have ways of making you talk. Al and I have been on The Rest is History a few times now, talking all things World War II with Tom and Dominic. If you've enjoyed their recent topics on 20th century history, then we have good news for you. Yes, that's right, Jim. We have our own show, all about the fascinating history of World War II.
我们的英雄奥德修斯发生了什么。再见。再见。你好，我是阿尔·默里，那是詹姆斯·霍兰德，第二次世界大战播客的主持人，我们有让你开口的方法。阿尔和我已经几次参加《历史的其余部分》，和汤姆与多米尼克谈论二战的所有事情。如果你喜欢他们最近关于20世纪历史的话题，那么我们有好消息告诉你。是的，没错，吉姆。我们有自己的节目，全是关于二战迷人的历史。
Every Tuesday and Thursday, WW2 Pod, we have ways of making you talk, discusses the fascinating people amazing innovations and terrible tragedies of this most pivotal period in human history. Yeah, and the bottom line is, other history has absolutely nothing on this. This past year alone, we've done series on visionary US presidents like FDR and Truman, HMS Hood v Bismarck, and Japan's Road to War. We've also explored daring night raids behind enemy lines like Brunovol and the nerve-wracking Atlantic convoys. And right now, we're doing the truly Titanic Operation Barbarossa, the Nazi German invasion of the Soviet Union in the summer of 1941. So now is a great time to subscribe and get into the action. Search, we have ways wherever you get your podcasts. That's we have ways wherever you get your podcasts.
每周二和周四，二战播客，我们有让你开口的方法，讨论人类历史上这个最关键时期迷人的人物、惊人的创新和可怕的悲剧。是的，底线是，其他历史根本无法与之相比。仅在过去的一年里，我们就制作了关于富有远见的美国总统如罗斯福和杜鲁门的系列节目，胡德号对俾斯麦号，以及日本的战争之路。我们还探索了敌后大胆的夜间突袭，如布鲁诺沃尔和令人神经紧张的大西洋护航队。现在，我们正在做真正泰坦尼克号般的巴巴罗萨行动，即1941年夏天纳粹德国入侵苏联。所以现在是订阅并参与行动的好时机。搜索，我们有方法，无论你在哪里获取播客。这就是我们有方法，无论你在哪里获取播客。
Hello and welcome to Doing It Anyway, a brand new series from Goalhanger. I'm Katty Kay. I've spent years studying the science and art of confidence, writing books about how we can close the confidence gap between men and women, and talking to experts and younger women about how to it on. Confidence means taking risks, acknowledging your fears and, well, doing it anyway. In this series, I'll be talking to psychologists, entrepreneurs and business leaders to unpack how you can rethink challenges and grow your own confidence. We'll talk about how to spot the difference between confidence and competence, how to deal with office politics and stolen credit and, yes, handling rejection, and ultimately how you can become a better leader, teammate, and, yes,
你好，欢迎来到《无论如何都要做》，这是Goalhanger的一个全新系列。我是凯蒂·凯。我花了很多年研究自信的科学和艺术，写书关于我们如何缩小男女之间的自信差距，并与专家和年轻女性谈论如何做到这一点。自信意味着冒险，承认你的恐惧，并且，好吧，无论如何都要做。在这个系列中，我将与心理学家、企业家和商业领袖交谈，探讨你如何重新思考挑战并增强自己的自信。我们将讨论如何区分自信和能力，如何处理办公室政治和被窃取的功劳，是的，处理拒绝，最终如何成为更好的领导者、队友，是的，
a better person. Doing it anyway with Katty Kay every Friday wherever you get your podcast. Hi everybody, it's Dominic here from The Rest is History. I just wanted to let you all know that on our sister podcast, the book club, we have just released an episode digging deep into George R.R. Martins, a Game of Thrones, the first book in his Song of Ice and Fire sequence. We go deep into the history behind Game of Thrones. So we go into the Wars of the Roses, Hadrian's Wall. We talk about the influence of Jera Tolkien and comparisons with the Lord of the Rings. But Tabby, we also talk, don't we, about George R.R.R. Martin's apparent stagnation and whether he's actually ever going to finish the books.
一个更好的人。《无论如何都要做》，凯蒂·凯，每周五，无论你在哪里获取播客。大家好，我是《历史的其余部分》的多米尼克。我只是想让你们都知道，在我们的姐妹播客，读书俱乐部，我们刚刚发布了一集深入挖掘乔治·R·R·马丁的《权力的游戏》，这是他的《冰与火之歌》系列的第一本书。我们深入探讨了《权力的游戏》背后的历史。所以我们进入了玫瑰战争，哈德良长城。我们谈论了J·R·R·托尔金的影响以及与《指环王》的比较。但是塔比，我们也谈论了，不是吗，关于乔治·R·R·马丁明显的停滞，以及他是否真的会完成这些书。
We investigate why it is that he has battled to finish them at all and whether he will ever be able to. But if you want to hear lots more about the history behind some of the greatest novels of all time, Fear Not. Coming up on the book club, we have The Leopard by Giuseppe Tomasi de Lampedusa, which is all about Italian unification. We talk about Searcy, where we delve into a particular part of the Odyssey. And then after that, we are doing the 39 steps, which Dominant you chose and you love. Please join us at the book club. It's loads of fun, and you will never find a better way to spend your life.
我们调查了为什么他一直在努力完成它们，以及他是否能够完成。但如果你想听到更多关于有史以来最伟大的小说背后的历史，不要害怕。在读书俱乐部即将推出的节目中，我们有朱塞佩·托马西·迪·兰佩杜萨的《豹》，全是关于意大利统一的。我们谈论瑟西，我们深入研究了《奥德赛》的特定部分。在那之后，我们正在做《三十九级台阶》，这是多米尼克你选择的，你很喜欢。请加入我们的读书俱乐部。这很有趣，你永远找不到比这更好的度过一生方式了。
Bye-bye. Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。